at the End of
[Music]
Time 13
O hey you guys what's going on is the
light okay Tom I know you're making
you're making that face yeah it looks
all right to me looks all right to me I
think I think the uh the camera's a
little up let me see I didn't touch it
though that's that's good right there
okay you sure yeah that's a happy medium
yeah yeah now those two lights were too
bright cuz I think we you turned that
one on super bright the other day cuz
you were giving me my injection and it
was too dark in he for me you see what
you were doing so I remember to turn
that one down but you know what I mean
uh but hey everybody hey Zach hey Tammy
what's going on you guys hey people that
aren't commenting but you're there
watching being
sneaky uh I think this is going to be um
a fun show if a kind of gruesome one
it's all about man eating animals yeah
and a lot of them well and we're not
just talking about like General man
eating animals we're talking about
specific animals that ate a bunch of
people yeah certain sharks certain
alligators certain lions ate a lot of
people so it's almost kind of like
almost like serial killer animals yeah
it's kind of like that it's kind of like
that yes it's going to be good like I
said I can think of a lot of horrible
Ways to Die um but right up at the top
of my list is getting eaten by something
yeah eating a Al is pretty bad I I
really that's that's right up there in
my top five especially like a shark or a
crocodile or an alligator something like
that no thanks no I think uh off the top
of my
head out of the ones we're going to
discuss the only one that actually eats
you while you're
alive always is a shark shark eats you
alive yeah some of the other ones kill
you first and then eat you which is
slightly better but still not great yeah
aligators and crocodiles drowned you
first
usually also not great but yeah but at
least you don't like experience the yeah
being chewed up by them right although
if an alligator gets you and starts
spinning or a [__] starts spinning it'll
cuz they it'll tear your [__] tear you
off a lot of times what happens is is
that if you fell in a bunch of C into
into into a body of water with a bunch
of crocodiles they tear you apart
fighting over you yeah so woohoo fresh
meat yeah yeah I saw I was at the
Alligator Farm in St Augustine when I
went there and whenever they feed the
Gators like everybody gets really
excited because they have a lot of
alligators there and they have some
crocodiles too but all the Alligators
that they have are like in one big
Central um habit like it's this big huge
swamp essentially that they built inside
the thing and so you can go and watch
them feed the Gators and the guy comes
with a like a wheelbarrow and it's got
they usually give them like um weasels I
think like shaved weasels yeah rats
stuff like that and so he does a show
for all the people you're on like this
raised you know walkway around the swamp
and the alligators know what time
feeding time is because they hear the
guy like coming down with the with the
thing and all the alligators come from
everywhere like hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of them and they're all
like come to this one spot and so he's
like over there like slinging the and
the and the alligators you don't really
think of alligators being able to do
this they can climb and they can jump
real high like out of the water now are
the weasels alive no okay they're shaved
just to make well well yeah I think they
just like make them easier to like
they're skinned rather skinned yeah
that's what I meant all right then that
you're talking about uh it's part of the
fur industry yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
what's what's left over from the fur
industry so he's like yeah so he's like
d and like the alligators are literally
climbing on top of each other and like
making a little crocodile you know like
you know like in um what was that zombie
movie where like all the zombies were
like piling on top of each other like
that it kind of looks like that except
alligators and they're all like climbing
up and someone were trying to climb up
the um like the the platform that he was
standing on and almost made it so I was
like Jesus Christ no thanks I wouldn't
like to fall in the middle of
that I don't think that's ever happened
at the alligator farm that I know of
that like some kid was like cuz you know
how some parents would be like hey look
little Timmy like look at the alligator
whoops you know what I mean like droing
the in the [__] water I don't think
it's happened there it might have
happened other places but you know what
I mean that I I can't imagine like
[__] seeing that or yeah it's awful
uh Zach said funny you're doing this
topic CU I just came from watching old
Happy Tree Friends videos I remember
those that's funny uh are you going to
talk about the monkey that ripped that
woman's face off well no because he's
not a Maneater and and two um I actually
wanted to do a separate show about
chimps that were raised as humans or
that you know humans raised yeah it
wasn't a monkey it was a chimp
chimpanzee it was a chimpanzee yeah and
chimpanzees are not monkeys that's not
that's not the only one that's that's
attacked a
human U there was one with you know just
bit a dude's face off bit his crotch off
he lived for a while I think he lived
yeah yeah cuz they'll go for your nuts
you're nuts in your face
yep and he didn't really know that guy
either it was just they were there
visiting a chimp that they owned there
they kind of raised it as a child and
they went there for its birthday they
had gave him the cake and everything and
it it got out that one and some other
males it was a big old big male and he
grabbed the dude he tried to go out the
cake I think first and
uh dude got in the way dude got in the
way of that chip that chip just chewed
him apart he lived though but he really
wanted disfigured yeah well actually I
don't think it took his face off took
most of his fingers off yeah I remember
and his nuts and his nuts and his dick
took off yeah yeah tore his genitals off
yeah which like I said um I don't think
they put it back on he just that's the
way he is now chimps will do that
imagine that uh and a lot yeah and some
of the ones that they even raised well
they even tell you like if you're going
to raise a chimp like for Hollywood
purposes and stuff like that they
usually use females because they're a
lot more chilled out or they can only um
use them up to a certain age like once
they go your adolesence forget it yeah
got all that testosterone they got to
send them like to a yeah all that all
that chimp
testosterone I got to look into
that are you going to inject that into
yourself now it might but like no I just
wanted to know is you going to tear my
arms off I want to know is is is it is
it the same compound it's probably the
same as human it's probably the same I
don't know it's just that they probably
have a lot of it scary probably have a
lot of it and they're not that smart
they're you know so they can't control
control it I guess yikes yeah American
Military 100 said awesome shirt Jenny
thank you very much yeah I don't get to
wear this as often cuz it's long sleeved
but it's actually like kind of cold in
Florida it's cold it's cold for Florida
it's like in it's in the 50s which it's
like woo it's winter time like we might
only get a couple of these I actually
got this from killstar they have a whole
Dario Argento collection I don't know if
it's still up there but they have like
some really cool pants that are kind of
have that pattern like um the saperia
wallpaper and [__] like that it's pretty
red they have like a bunch of
[__] they had a dress that was like from
uh saperia and it was kind of like lime
green it was pretty awesome why is my
phone ringing I don't know I don't know
me calling you well obviously but it's
nobody uh ganther says Tim Treadwell was
eaten alive and he filmed it bite by
bite as seen in Grizzly Man by Veron
Herzog yeah that's um his girlfriend got
eaten too yeah I always kind I've seen
parts of that documentary I can't bring
myself to watch it even though though I
know well they have the audio of the
attack right the complete audio yeah
yeah and it's like I kind of started
listening to it and I'm just like I
don't know man it's like I can't unhear
this so it wasn't that bad it wasn't
that bad no I mean just like bunch bunch
of like no no no like a bunch of
screaming then screaming yeah he was
screaming but I think well I think it
would be worse for me because it's like
I know what it is you know what I mean
if it was just like didn't have any
context it wouldn't be that bad but it's
like I know what's happening and I can
picture it so she started screaming too
well I guess so she was screaming
through the whole thing but then it got
her they got her after him yeah
that's I guess she didn't run well maybe
she was trying to help him yeah I think
she was I mean yeah I mean you'd be mad
if like a bear started eating you and
like I was like bye good luck you know
what I mean yeah but there's there that
was a gzz and there just I know but I'm
just saying it evidently a huge one and
there's just nothing you can do well I
know that i' expect you to [__] run I
probably I probably wouldn't be able to
you know I mean my I think my first
instinct would be to try to help you I
would have been yelling run he prob I
think he did tell her to run I think he
did tell her to run yeah he probably did
yeah but yeah unforeseen just said he
kept screaming for his girlfriend to
just run away yeah yeah yeah but yeah
she stayed and tried to stayed and it
cost her her life and and it ate her but
had she actually gotten some distance
away that probably would have let her go
I know but [__] man can you imagine like
living with that I don't know if I'd be
able to live with that to be honest yeah
cuz I think I did remember him [__]
tell her tell her to run run cuz like I
said you can never unsee that it's like
hey a bear ate my boyfriend like right
in front of my that would be [__]
awful I would just like never be able to
I would never get over that that would
he was pushing it though I know he was
going up and just meeting any old
Grizzly that he saw pretty much there
and the the one that he saw and says I
don't know I don't like that guy he goes
if I get eaten it's going to be that one
and that was the one later the one thate
him later on it was that because yeah he
was around them enough that he knew
their person personalities yeah and he's
like yeah that one's that one's an
[__] yeah turned out he was right I
think he was he was old and
week yeah for a bear so he wasn't
getting if I remember correctly he
wasn't getting fed
regularly yeah he was on it was a bear
on the edge he's a bear on the edge yeah
well when they're when when they're in
their Prime they're not real desperate
yeah and as we'll see like a lot of
these very famous Mayon eaters
um not all of them but some of the ones
after they killed them and they found
out what the deal was like autopsy them
or whatever A lot of them had been
injured in particular ways that made it
so that they couldn't really hunt their
regular prey anymore which might have
explained why they started praying on
humans because some of them prayed on
humans like specifically and we're not
kidding because some of these like
animals killed hundreds sometimes
thousands of
people um of Fred said long ago there
was once a railroad construction that
was being stoed by two lions yeah we're
going to talk about that um and the 1996
movie the ghost in the darkness is a
biic about it yeah we're going to talk
about that um and there there was that
and then there was a um like a pride of
lions also that killed a bunch of
people um Danny Rowling said there was a
Texas bar owner I remember hearing about
this who had Gators on the bar's
property and he would occasionally feed
his employees or girlfriends or dogs uh
cats Etc until he got caught yeah like
they were alligators underneath the bark
didn't they yeah they made a movie about
him right yeah Toby Hooper made a film
about the guy yeah I thought he did he
feed girlfriends to to the to the AL
well I guess if they pissed him off
they're like yeah bye babe damn just
yeah well alive or it must have been
dead I don't know yeah yeah slash Fred
said I believe the movie was called
crocodile
Danny oh no eaten alive 1976 oh yeah
yeah yeah Toby ho is eatting alive I
don't think we reviewed that maybe we
should because I think that's on Amazon
Prime actually I was thinking about
watching it the other day matter of fact
but uh cuz there's another movie called
eating alive that I think is a cannibal
movie but that's two different movies
but yeah that one is kind of about the
crocodile thing or the alligator thing
he was Gator it was Gators right yeah
cuz it was Texas um yeah he fed fed them
alive to the Gators
damn he wasn't [__] around I guess
yeah Jesus Christ what did he feed his
girlfriend to the gator for I mean
nobody does anything to Desert well I
can't say that if you're if you're a
serial killer yeah yeah throw to the
gator girlfriend but it's like other
than that it's just like did the
girlfriends know that he was feeding
people
though yeah I don't know sometimes a
girlfriend knows of Aer killer knows
what he's doing and then she ends up she
ends up in his sights we got to do a
show on that yeah that kind of that
should probably have a whole show yeah
somebody was mentioning earlier um oh
grur said word on the street is Jimmy
hofa was fed to pigs at a farm in
Michigan owned by Mobsters although I've
heard that they that is a decent way to
get with because pigs you don't really
think about pigs cuz you know bacon and
you know Wilbur and everything but um
but pigs are actually if you throw like
a person in there that can't get away
like into a bunch of pigs they will
absolutely eat a person the best lead
the the the best lead that that was the
most
plausible was what happened to Jimmy
Hoff is what they normally did because
they had done it to other guys the the
guys that they suspect killed
him they shot him they they got him
alone he didn't know that they were
going to kill him he thought he was a
bunch around friends they shot him shot
him in the back of the head with like a
22 they wrapped him up they put him in
the trunk of a car old jalap and they
drove it to the scrapyard where
gangsters worked they or owned the
scrapyard I don't remember I know they
worked there at least they took the car
crushed it and then melted it they
crushed it into a 3X3 cube with him in
it and then they melted it melted it
down into the damn Forge and that's what
happened to him yeah you wouldn't really
be able to find any of right yeah which
is that's a good way of getting rid of
and they didn't have to hide it from the
employees cuz it was the employees just
that was their oh it's one of those cars
okay yeah you know one of those special
Cars one of special cars that's what
they did what are the special cards
there's nothing left he burned off into
slag yeah
vaporized the thing about pigs it's
interesting because I was just reading
some articles about man eating animals
and there aren't any specific pigs that
went Maneater as far as they know but as
recently as 2019 evidently there was a
woman in Texas who was attacked killed
and partially eaten by a bunch of feral
Hogs I don't know what the situation was
there but it's just like I just saw that
on the Wikipedia page and I was just
like holy [__] [__] that was only
like a couple years ago so it does
happen so pigs are not the gentle
little uh pigs are mean little yeah
they're they're kind of [__] yeah
and they will absolutely eat you they
will eat you if given your own mother if
given the opportunity yeah I've heard
Farm
stories or guy will go in there and
Slaughter an old sa well that's the
mother to the to the other pigs that are
in there and they'll see him [__]
kill her kill
her um cut her up and then barbecue her
yeah all right and then pigs begging for
some of that meat it's like oh my
delicious mom yeah M that smells so good
cuz there's something about them they're
they just something about them I mean
you know I don't think you could do that
with a
dog I think if dogs saw you kill another
dog especially if they knew it and then
you started C nobody do that experiment
I don't think they'd ask for any food
they're like no I don't know though cuz
dogs will kind of eat anything so I
don't know I think they yeah maybe maybe
it just go maybe they no longer become
the friend or the mother or whatever
it's now just food yeah May they don't
really think about it think about it
that way cuz look man I've heard about
cuz I know people that that have both
dogs and cats as pets and they're like
dogs will absolutely eat cat turds right
out of the litter box they do not give a
single [__] yeah
so well it smells good smells terrible
and they they they they think it smells
good which I'm just kind of like cats
and dogs like stuff that stinks okay for
some reason well I mean the thing about
it though is that cats aren't really
that bad it's like yeah the you know our
cats e like stinky ass fish that's kind
of their favorite thing but it's just
like I don't they wouldn't eat their own
poop no or their own vomit I've never
seen them do that but I've seen dogs do
that yeah I've seen dogs at the
farm horse will [__] drop a [__]
load and the dogs will run up and just
eat fresh steaming horse apples yeah
like wow that was good man you don't eat
that it's like stop it you're dis
hot the funny thing is is that it's
sterile out out of a horse it's pretty
sterile
because you know it's just hay but I
know yeah hey it's hay and it's grur
says my dog eats her turds as soon as
she drops them really she eats her own
turds damn what's the point of like even
pooping them out if you're just going to
eat them again that's ridiculous I mean
the whole digestive system evolved like
to kind of Forstall that possibility
you're supposed to be getting rid of
that not eating it back up again they
don't know what they're
doing how have they liveed so long doing
that kind of [__] man I can't see him
doing that in the wild that's what I
maybe it's a domestication thing like us
I mean yeah they just start getting
strange Behavior that's crazy they get
civilized problems tny rolling said
Second
Harvest that's so gross oh my God I'm
getting so gross out right now but yeah
I mean yeah the the alligator guy's name
is Joe ball that's right he's in my
topic list Joe ball the alligator man I
think I've actually put him in the poll
a couple times but it doesn't win so it
is it is on my top in list I thought it
was but
uh gther said we feed her Gourmet dog
food so they're Gourmet turds okay so
maybe they maybe they taste even better
the second time who
knows it's me Jay said their stomachs
have crazy stomach acids they can handle
eating [__] I guess so I mean it doesn't
really seem to have any they can e
detrimental effect they can eat car yeah
I see them eat Rogue K and ch all the
time they get super excited about that
like they don't even care how long it's
been sitting there they're scavenger
they'll e anything I guess yeah but
that's [__] crazy like I said I do
kind of feel like cats will eat some
gross [__] too but they seem more
Discerning you know yeah Zach says no
stop I haven't eaten dinner yet yeah
sorry well we'll save you some money you
don't have to buy dinner now because
you're so grossed out you can't eat
anything should we go ahead and uh start
the first uh yeah let's start talking
about the first thing don't we have to
do a shout out to our uh yes let's do a
shout out to our sponsor SL affiliate
company which is
audible as I've mentioned on the show
many many times audible is one of the
world's if not the world's largest
repository of audiobooks podcasts and
other audio
entertainment uh so if you click the
link in the description box you will get
a
30-day free uh trial of audible and uh
during that 30 days you can listen to as
much stuff as you want to with no
including Jenny's books including my
books cuz all my books almost all of my
books are on there in audio format yep
so you can listen to all those if you
want parmal books among many other
things because like I said you can
listen to a lot of stuff in 30 days
that's a long time yep uh so yeah and
also if you do the deal you also get one
free credit to spend on whatever you
want and you can keep that forever and
if you're already an Amazon Prime member
you get two free credits uh that you can
spend and again whatever you buy with
those credits you get to keep them
forever so yeah uh audible it's really
cool I use it you should use it too
please click on the link in the
description box and full disclosure we
get a small commission if you sign up
through that link but yeah it's audible
it's awesome another way to support the
show yeah alrighty so let's talk about
some man eating animals so we brought up
Grizzly Man before yeah um but here is a
case now this actually happened in
Japan uh this was also a bear back in
1915 now this just says brown bear uh
brown bear kind of covers I kind of feel
like that covers grizzly bear too does
it not I think I think are they slightly
different I mean I think the ones in
Asia may be like a slightly different
species um because you know here in
Florida we have black bears and black
bears very very very very rarely attack
humans very rarely they're not super
aggressive although it's the most common
type to be attacked by that's because
they're around hum because that's
because they're around humans all the
time they're mostly they're not
interested in humans they're pretty
docile but yeah they mostly just go
through your garbage cans now if you
like surprise them when you come out one
morning then yeah they might they might
attack you but um usually they don't
kill you though yeah um drag you out
throw you and then run and then yeah
right uh because they're not you know
they don't seem to see people as
food so back in 1915 in Japan there was
a case of a brown bear that kind of went
on a rampage just like in this one
Village which is kind of crazy now if
okay this is crazy this is like a
trivial fact that I that I did not know
so if somebody asked you what is the
most dangerous wild animal in Japan in
terms of how many people are killed
every year by it what do what would your
answer
be something kind of like uh some
probably something in the
water it has to be a land animal it
doesn't have to be it can be any animal
just any I know that I know that people
get killed by those giant salamanders
that they used
to yeah do you know that yeah they bite
you and drown you yeah especially if
you're a kid um so if it's not that I'd
probably say it was a bear yeah nope dog
nope I don't know giant hornet okay yeah
yeah the Japanese giant hornet they had
him in Korea kills 40 people a year
which is a lot for a hornet yeah those
[__] are big too they're scary murder
Hornet yeah they can just three of them
can wipe out an entire
beehive yeah they're ass you can see it
yeah you can they got video of it slow
motion video of those things killing all
those bees one by one just working all
day to kill the entire Hive and to go in
there and get all the H honey they want
they're big they had them in Korea I
only see dead ones though You' see a
dead one it' be like that big huge the
head on it was like the size of a
nickel [__] spooky I think I would
[__] pass out if I saw an insect that
big yeah eyes eyes like it's making eye
contact with you pretty hey I'm going to
[__] you up
yeah big they're bigger than a longer
than a June beetle but similar in Mass
yeah remember the June be be yeah and
you know this is Florida we got some big
ass bugs in here too but you know what I
mean [__] man Danny says bigfoots eat
humans sometimes I mean maybe they do
you can't prove they don't ganther says
we once caught our dog noshing on a used
tampon she got out of the bathroom waist
bin yeah I've heard of dogs doing that
too damn like I said dogs leave fing
anything man it's so gross but yeah so
even though the the murder Hornet the
giant hornet in Japan actually kills
more people than any other
animal um the largest Predator that they
have there is the brown bear and this
attack that happened in 1915 was the
worst bear attack in history uh so yeah
it took place in this little bitty
Village called um s betsu I'm not sure
if I'm pronouncing that correctly I may
have to correct something though what's
that I don't think a bear is a predator
I think it's classified as a as a well
this one was I think it's I think it's
classified as as as an opportunist or a
scavenger yeah because they eat a lot of
you know it's not like a a lion that
only hunts down you know the animals
like that only hunt other animals in
Edom Bears don't do that they they will
hunt down animals they mostly fishing
they fish and they uh uh berries and
they'll dig stuff up and eat it they're
just like an opportunist they tend not
to be even Grizzlies they're not they're
not uh they're not about hunting [__]
down and killing it really that's the
side
gig this particular bear I almost want
to
say that he did the [__] that he did
because of Revenge yeah okay which we
got the idea for this show to do the
show from um that show with William
Shatner The Unexplained they did a show
about maning humans and they were
talking about I don't think we were
talking about on this show but they
talked about a particular I think it was
a tiger yeah in Russia yeah in Russia
that like a guy shot her and then she
tracked him back to his house and ate
him yeah cuz she was mad yeah uh so it
was this big long thing about like can
an animal feel you know can like track
and it took like a while for her to like
track him down and she waited like
outside his house remember that yeah
like for 3 days or something like that
till he came home from wherever he was
and then she jumped on him like she was
like you [__] you shot me he
must have just grazed it yeah yeah yeah
yeah but this one I kind of feel like
okay so let me know if you think that's
what's going on here because this kind
of sounds like a Revenge scenario to me
so this this Village at the time in 1915
was very very small so there wasn't like
a lot of people living here and it was
kind of like still a sort of like
pioneer like a wild area and there was
like a lot of brown bears in the area um
they didn't generally attack people or
anything like that but there was this
big male bear who they later named um
Kake now he used to come into the
village and eat their corn like after
they had picked it and like they had it
like lay out and stuff and he would come
in and be like oh for me and then he
would start eating it so they're like
hey bear that's our corn [__] off and so
two villagers shot him and I don't know
what part of the body they shot him in
but it obviously it didn't kill him and
he ran back to like in the mountains
this is what year was this 1915 okay I'm
trying to put together all right 1915
yeah all right they they they were using
real small caliber stuff in Japan in
those years okay so it must have must
have been something like 22 long
rifle you
know I mean very weak prob I wasn't a
hunting rifle yeah and I kind of feel
like that was maybe the case with some
of these animals cuz a lot of these
animals like did get shot and then they
come back and yeah [__] people up yeah a
bear a bear large bear could absorb a
lot of 22 long rifle yeah you know it
would hurt I mean this was a big ass it
was this was a big ass bear too
yeah so cuz I mean you and you can see
why the villagers probably thought this
they're just like well if we shoot him
even if it doesn't kill him like you
know he'll be scared and he won't come
back you know what I mean um that's not
what happened unfortunately for for many
of the people in the village what
happened in early December of 1915 the
bear comes back into the village he
walks into a house that belongs to the
OT family OT yeah now there the only
people in there was like um a woman she
was like the wife of the farmer and a
baby I don't know if it was her baby or
if it was a baby she was
babysitting so the bear comes in goes
right for the baby and kills the baby hm
and then goes right for the woman and
like starts attacking the woman now she
tried to like fight the bear off she was
like whacking him with [__] like logs
from the fireplace and [__] like that
but obviously this is you know this bear
was like enormous so it basically like
dragged her out the house and like into
the
woods so people hear all the screaming
they run to the house there's blood
everywhere like all over the [__]
walls and [__] like that so all the
dudes like they figure out it's like oh
that was that [__] bear so they run
into the wood WS like to try and kill
the bear now they found the bear and
they shot him again but it still didn't
kill him yeah they're using 22 or
something like 16 or 20 gauge shotgun
probably with bird shot or small pellets
like that I don't think Japanese
civilians were allowed to own anything
real powerful definitely nothing
military and their militaries then were
using bolt action rifles
so it's this is a Japan thing
people in the United States had the had
the ability they had the weapons
necessary to kill bear with with a
single shot but this just in this story
right now this Bears absorbed too many
rounds which means that these people
were undergunned pretty badly they're
just pissing the bear off if it was
something yeah that's hbj just said
they're just pissing him off at this
point yeah yeah something like any small
gauge buck shot which they or or or shot
out of a shotgun
I wouldn't even hunt a bear with [__]
even buck shot I don't even think i' I
don't think I'd hunt one even with a
slug shotgun slugs I would don't really
trust it that's something if you're
going to go after a large bear you want
a high powerered rifle you know 308 or
762 at least just starting with that you
go up into 7 mm M 7 millimeter Magnum
you know that that'd be a good one for
that you know 50 cal you can get that
that'd be great for Bear now you could
they did HT bear
with um C uh [__] even even muskets
okay
um both flint lock and um p u percussion
cap
rifles but they were at least 50 caliber
big heavy lead ball a lot of it was 54
caliber it's a low velocity but it's a
real heavy bullet moving slow but it's
soft lead and it just smears when and it
gets in there like a hollow point just
tears up it'll tear up a
bear I don't think in Japan they they
allowed civilians to have anything like
that so they're probably using like buck
shot but real small Buckshot we call it
bird shot it's probably what they're
using for it's a Fowler it's for
shooting down
Birds they're tiny pellets about as
small as a bb or smaller a bunch of them
that will not penetrate a a bear hide
very well that'll just piss that bear
off especially if there's any distance
cuz it slowed down you know nothing
Beyond 25
M no you're up close with it yeah you'll
bore a hole through it but that's deadly
close on on a bear an angry
bear they're just under gun they're
pissing the bear off making it worse
yeah I'm just going to leave how about
that yeah unforeseen says apparently
they did make a movie in 1990 about this
called yellow fangs well now I'm GNA
have to see that but yeah so so they
shot the Bears I'm guessing this is the
third time
but of course it didn't kill him like I
said it's just now it's just making him
mad now the animal runs off again they
did find the woman's um partially eaten
body which is [__] up he kind of
buried it a little bit cuz he's saving
it for later yeah come back for it yeah
which you know that [__] up so then
later on I don't know if it was the same
day or the next day but the bear comes
back into the village and goes back to
the same house again and I guess some of
the villagers like saw him going in
there like oh [__] we're got to go over
there and get him so like all of them go
into that house but the bear somehow
eluded them and got out of that house
and went to another house that had
people in it like another family called
the mioke family and started maing
everybody in there yeah um now some of
the people did get out of the house like
holy [__] and they like ran out of the
house two little kids got killed and a
pregnant woman they abandoned the women
and children yeah it's like the guys
were like bye good luck with
that good luck fighting off the bear
honey
yeah yeah um which is [__] up yeah a
brown bear can get pretty big this one
um I believe he was 10 feet tall yeah
and weighed almost 900 lb that's a size
of a Grizz so yeah he was a big [__]
he was a big [__] and and they said he
was much bigger than uh the other brown
bears in the area and he was obviously
much angrier and hungrier than the other
ones as well because apparently there
were a lot of brown bears in this area
and they hadn't really as far as I know
like bothered anybody but this this one
he's also wounded at this point like I
said it might have been because he was
mad that they drove him out of the
village for eating their corn yeah and
so he's like I'm just going to come back
and [__] him up yeah when they're
wounded they'll eat things that they
wouldn't normally eat he's desperate you
guys are hurting me I'm like you're
going to pay he's eating yeah because
they got to heal up man they need the
protein yeah I mean that's what it is
he's like well these are the these are
the people that shot me so I'm just
going to eat them but meat's meat so
yeah so all the the guard people the
other people in the village they come
back obviously they see these two dead
kids and like dead pregnant woman with
like her [__] fet is like torn out of
the belly and [__] like that it's like
yeah it's [__] horrible um so yeah so
what's his body count out that's six
people six people he's killed and at
this point most of the villagers were
like [__] this and they just like left
you know what I mean cuz they're like
we're we don't want to deal with this it
tells me they were basically unarmed
yeah so could stand and fight at this
point um I guess there was a dude in the
area that was kind of known for hunting
bears like he was kind of famous for it
and so he comes to the Village to see
what he can do about it and his opinion
was that this bear had probably killed
people before like I said maybe he was
like a seral killer kind of bear or
something now at first he was just like
yeah I don't want to get involved but he
did eventually get it wasn't just him he
had like um some of the other villagers
like did help him out and stuff and so
he did actually finally manage to kill
the bear uh a few days after uh those
because this was only like a week where
this whole like Rampage happen so yeah
so after they killed him uh like I said
he was about 10 ft tall uh 840b that's
how much he weighed um try to go up
against that yeah that's not man meat
that's bear meat [__] that 800 lb like I
said I don't want to get eaten by a bear
either it's you know what I mean that's
just that sounds awful yeah how they
kill you is they usually grab you by the
throat and just crush it yeah bite a big
piece out or they grab you by the head
or the throat and they just start
crushing gwing pulling the [__] skin
off the head
usually yeah canine teeth going through
your
skull they're not chokers they're
chewers yeah bad way to go that's yeah
that's got to be a bad way to go yeah
and if you want to see like a like a
good fictional movie about a bear attack
please see the movie Back Country um
because I feel like it's really
underrated and there is a
horrific bear attack in that and it
looks really realistic like the um the
special effects are really good it's
basically I think it's partially based
on a true story but it's like a husband
and wife or I think um I think he was
actually gonna ask her to marry him like
on this camping trip
so he was going to be like engaged or
whatever and um and he gets eaten by the
bear and then the rest of the movie like
pretty early spoiler alert like pretty
early on in the movie and then the rest
of the movie is her trying to escape
from the bear because the bear is like
chasing her and so it's kind of based on
a true story but it's really good it's a
good lick suspenseful movie yeah if you
if you have if I had a choice between
eaten by a bear and eaten by a lion or
tiger I'd choose a big cat yeah I would
too cuz they at least like kind of go
for your throat and like kind of Choke
the life out of you before yeah they'll
they put that would be fun either they
hook you with some fan they hook you
with some claws so you can't run they
pull you in they get on top of you they
grab you around the throat and just bite
and you lose Consciousness they'll hold
you like that for a long time and
they'll eat you and now a lot of times
while they're choking you out their
buddies trying to get a bite out of you
yeah so that might be another Factor
you're alive the other one's trying to
take off part of your leg you know but y
if you're by yourself or excuse me if
that line is by itself
it's going to be a more Humane death
than a bear bears aren't expert Killers
they're they're more like a scavenger
and when they're pissed off they're just
going to bite and crush and Pull and
whack at you yeah and whack with the
claws they're going to try to crush your
head and crush your
neck yeah and you know well hey we got
proof that dude that dude the Grizzly
Man he screamed for a long time I heard
it so that's why I didn't want to listen
to the whole thing because I said I
can't unhear that and picture every
single of it they're not they're not
efficient killers they take they take
their
time yeah yeah that would oh that would
be horrible that'd be
horrible Danny says that old woman that
recently got eaten by a gator in Florida
while walking her dog along the water's
edge must have not grown up in Florida
cuz who does that in Florida yeah it's
not a great idea I have seen people
doing it but honestly I mean I was born
here so I just assume that any body of
water of any size probably has at least
one alligator in it and so I'm just like
not going to fart around down there by
it you just go out there at night and
take a high powerered flashlight and
swing it across that water if if there's
alligators out there you'll see glowing
eyes looking back at you at at water
level they're really reflective eye yeah
if you don't see any ref they're
everywhere if you don't see any
Reflections they're not in there they
don't like a body of water if it's real
small it's small they'll be in there
maybe a day or so yeah cuzz they move
around like from pond to Pond but if
it's kind of a a large size like a a
decent sized lake or something like that
yeah there's going to be lots of them in
there so yeah don't take your kids right
to the edge don't take your pets to the
edge even in Disneyland one got eaten
yep a kid did yeah so let the kid get
down there by the by the water just
don't seriously it's Florida we're
serious please don't do that outside the
Disneyland parking lot and it bam they
won they won't go after an adult but not
usually they'll go after a kid or a dog
or or a dog or a cat or something like
that yeah they absolutely will yeah um
they wouldn't usually attack a grown
person unless circumstances were a
particular way they're not about any
trouble but alligators are actually
pretty shy they're not yeah it's like
they're they're frightening animals but
they're not super aggressive now
crocodiles on the other hand yeah a
little bit different story um they will
eat people all day long they don't care
how big you are alligators just want to
they want to live a chill life and they
want to easy prey yeah they just take
you to the they just grab you and take
you to the bottom and drown
you then they'll hide your body for a
week or maybe three days in the Flor of
the Sun and you'll soften up a bit and
then they'll e because they can't chew
they have to swallow they can tear
things into pieces and just gulp it down
yeah they're just like they can't really
chew they don't have any teeth like in
the yeah yeah well their jaw only opens
and closes and it doesn't grind yeah so
so they they prefer stuff to to be kind
of soft they let it rot a little bit
that's why it's the the thing about the
bite strength is they have really good
bite strength going down but coming up
they don't have that's that's why you
can usually kind of hold their mouth
shut like with your hands you can also
tape it and yeah cuz if you go to like
the alligator farm or something like
that they'll let you like pet gator like
small Gators and stuff and they always
have like duct tape around their mouth
CU they can't open it you know what I
mean you can also befriend an alligator
a lot of people have done it sounds
strange I I wouldn't they can get used
to a particular person and they'll let
you pet them and they'll come to your
house probably not food unless I'm real
hungry one day and need a snack yeah
it's
weird you can befriend one in certain
circumstan it's kind of weird and
justice for me said I live in Melbourne
oh that's not far from here uh saw a
decent sized gator in a ditch they
really are everywhere I saw one running
across
us92 booking it almost getting hit by a
car and I was just like look at that
that is the most Florida thing I've ever
seen I saw s alligator running across
the high I saw a snapping turtle 4T in
diameter walking down the sidewalk old
Sanford compan just a
nice grimed Comm he a big yeah he was a
big guy gigantic 4 foot diameter flat
snapping turtle just
walking going to another going to
another Pond another Pond cuz there's
little ponds everywhere
yeah but yeah you I just
assume I just assume that if there's a
body of water that it probably has an
alligator in it it's probably safer to
assume that because there probably is
one in there it's not probably not going
to pop out and E you but I wouldn't take
Pooky out by it like or or Bambi or take
a kid by it no way no
way unless you checked yeah and the
thing about it is that I used to go to
Alexander Springs a lot when I was
younger which is in
Okala and they have um the one spot
where you can swim is kind of netted off
a little bit there's fish and everything
um but if you go in the other area
that's like where it's canals and stuff
there's alligators all over the place
however alligators do occasionally get
into the swimming area yeah um and I was
there a couple times when that happened
in the daytime they're mostly on the
bottom sleeping yeah they can sleep for
hours and hours and hours holding their
breath underneath there but in the night
time they're up at the surface you see
the eyeses
yeah but yeah I was at Alexander Springs
one time and I was just in the swimming
area and then I glanced over and like
right over there I'm like oh [__] and
they were just kind of like um hey
alligator might y'all might want to get
out
of normally they try to keep them out of
the swimming area but you can't you know
keep them out there's not a you know
there's not a wall or anything like that
it's just kind of like a net thing and
if they can kind of get out and walk
around so it's not really that big of a
deal but yeah um so yeah so this they so
they got this bear apparently they cut
his stomach open and Story Goes that
there were human remains in his stomach
so that's how he was EA people cuz he
was eating people um and some of the
people that had actually survived the
attacks by the bear um actually died
later of their wounds so his body count
was actually much higher right um and
after this happened uh the rest of the
villagers said [__] this place maybe
thinking it was cursed or something and
they moved out um so I don't even know
if there's anybody living in that town
or if that town even exists anymore cuz
like I said it was just like a little
bitty Village this was 193 who killed it
and how yeah I said who killed it it was
um a just a bear hunter I don't know I
don't know what his name was but they
had him come from like another Village
he was kind of known for hunting bears
he came equipped with the right right
[__] rifles what happened yeah he's
just like yeah I'm going cuz he did kill
it like cuz I think the first attack was
on December 9th and then he killed it on
the 15th yeah so it was only like six
days it's like in
between um yeah in Justice for me said
there was a guy who befriended a Croc
down in South America some time ago he
was famous for it yeah yeah I mean I
wouldn't but it takes a long time you
have to feed them they got to get used
to you then you have to be able to get
in the water with it and uh they're
underneath the water I've seen dudes
underneath the water petting them you
know they got snorkel
on and uh the allig alligator lets him
do stuff you know he'll roll it up roll
it over upside down rub its belly
underneath the water you know so you can
befriend one and it's but it's only that
one dude it would might attack somebody
else you know even though like I said
they're not that aggressive usually
especially to other things in the water
they're aggressive to things on the bank
yeah that's anything on the bank is food
well they they catch stuff on the water
too but I don't know fish and [__] Danny
says there was a homeless guy who went
swimming in Florida water just to
retreated with soccer ball and got
killed by a gator yeah definitely a
Darwin Award right there yeah I mean big
they are too you don't need anything
that bad that's in the water just get
out of there there are truly huge
alligators and I wouldn't trust one
remember that video that went viral of
that one just like strolling through the
golf course yeah and for a while the
alligator was so big that everybody
thought it was fake it and then they
were like no it was real cuz they had
one from like a bunch of different
phones and like a bunch of different
angles it was literally the size of a
dragon it was [__] enormous and he's
just like walking dead through the
[__] cuz there was a lot of people
golfing that day and they were like holy
[__] look at that yeah it was yeah I
thought it was fake too CU I'm like oh
my God that thing is so [__] huge
alligators don't get as big as
crocodiles but they get still big they
get I mean they're still big enough to
like I don't think they know how big
they actually get actually yeah they
might not because there's fossils of
ancient ones that were [__] huge man
almost twice the size you have now they
don't seem to die of old age uh they've
never observed one dying of old age and
an old one the older they get the bigger
they get the more food that they have
the bigger they get um and an old one at
100 years old is just as Lively as a
young one that's only a few years old so
I don't think they die old age they die
because they get so big they can't feed
themselves or they get so big that they
attract attention and people kill them
but I think maybe back in prehistoric
times those things could maybe live to
maybe 200 years old and get huge and get
like a Norman yeah and there were there
was plenty of [__] protein lots of
big animals around to eat so they can
just continue to grow and grow and grow
like the those old those old fossils of
a [__] 30 foot alligator or crocodile
type thing it's probably just a regular
alligator or crocodile a modern one
could probably get to that size if it's
if it's for 200 years and eating a [__]
ton of protein yeah it' probably do it
but an alligator would never live 200
years in today's environment yes
too built up and too built up people
would see that [__] once it got to about
[__] 15 16t they go that thing's a
menace it can't hide they they kill
it but I don't you know the same thing
with gar I think gar used can get real
big well same thing with like this big
ass catfish too cuz remember how big
Catfish used to get and I know Jeremy
Wade every now and then he'll catch like
a b like a enormous one but I don't
think they're as common as they seen
seen photographs from the 1920s of
Louisiana alligator guard it's a big old
[__] eel with a head on it like an
alligator and I've never seen a [__]
G that big yeah I think the biggest one
I ever saw was like 4 feet yeah no these
things were [__] like 12 feet long
yeah I've never seen one that big so
it's just like what the [__] I don't I
don't think in modern times they can get
that big because people too many people
fishing now but in the 20s those things
those things may have been 150 years old
in the 20s you don't know cuz we don't
know how long how long live and that's
kind of the thing we've been talking
about that with crocodiles and
alligators like reptilians that it's
like I'm not really entirely sure they
know what the outer edge of their
lifespan is and like you said and some
fish are like that too like if they have
sufficient food and they're not um you
know wounded or they're not hunted or
anything like that then they can just
keep on growing they just grow to fit
the foods right they're not like mammals
where they get to a certain size and
stop right they just keep on getting
bigger as long as the environment is and
they don't get feeble right a 100y old
alligator is Lively like he's not he's
like he's not old he's just big but they
require a lot of protein every day yeah
you got to eat a lot to maintain the
body that size and chances of him making
it over time in in the modern world
getting his daily protein to continue
growing uh no he's not GNA be able to
find that amount of food
anymore I think that's kind of the case
with a lot of animals whether it's just
kind of like I said just alligators
crocodiles sharks um catfish I think
like I said cuz we used to watch the you
know Jeremy Wade's show River Monsters
that he was always looking for those big
ass catfish like some of which did kill
people yeah big enough to swallow you
and it was big enough to swallow a
person and he did actually catch a
couple yeah that were easily big enough
to swallow a person there are wood cuts
from the European Middle Ages of them
showing their Bountiful Harvest they'd
show big piles of [__] uh
wheat loaves of bread next to it
chickens big a cow and right next to it
a [__] catfish but it's the same size
as the cow you go that's got to just be
a representation if Jeremy Wade proved
no that's how big that catfish actually
was yeah because he caught some almost
out size cuz in the Medieval Era there
was no rod and reel the only way they
could fish is with a net yeah and those
things were living in places where you
couldn't use a net yeah so fish could
live to be hundreds of years old old and
they got that big catfish the size of a
[__]
cow nowadays you're only going to find
it something like that like an Amazon
yeah where there aren't any
people and [__] catfish big enough to
swallow a man and they're still around
yeah um because he specifically goes to
places where there are reports of people
being taken in rivers by something that
they think is a big ass fish and he
wants to go and find out if it really is
a big ass fish and in a few cases that
one show in particular where he hauled
that catfish out of the water I was like
holy [__] [__] it was enormous yeah
all these uh medieval stories about lake
monsters and Lake demons it's catfish
that's what they're talking about yeah
they got huge in the medieval period
which is funny I never really thought
about it before cuz [__] man I grew up
eating catfish I'm from the south and
it's like we used to catch them
sometimes but they were little you know
what I mean it's like you know it's yeah
like we'd catch catfish like that big
and it's like so it never occurred to me
that there were catfish out there that
like you said we as big as like a cow
big as a cow like you said so um if they
live long enough and they got enough
food so when I see that when I see him
catch one I'm just kind of like oh no
matter of fact what Jeremy said is he
said the medievals could not get catfish
that big by using a net or they didn't
have rod and reel and they weren't
getting them with a net they were doing
it by dredging the [__] Lake the pond
right they [__] not dredging what do
you call it emptying it yeah they they
big a a channel and [__] and then
when you got up to the pond you broke
through the wall and all the water would
drain out to Low Land and the water
level of the [__] Pond would go down
to only a couple feet and it would you
could then a whole bunch of people could
walk in there and just take all the fish
well they would do that there'd be like
four or five [__] catfish in there
maybe 200 years old
each [__] the size of cows yeah feed
a whole bunch of people and then all the
little ones actually like younglings the
[__] that youed that's like this big
yeah [__] like we were catching when
they could catch those with Nets that's
the only ones they were catching they
weren't catching the real old
ones now another fish that I've seen
real big ones and this is an ocean fish
is a grouper and I didn't realize how
big they got either but they get really
really big a tuna can get huge oh yeah
tuna get big too which like I said when
I was growing up I didn't realize that
because you know tuna comes in a can
yeah so you just think of them as like
can size but no tuna are like to the
size of a cow yeah they're [__]
enormous they're [__] enormous uh
yeah Danny says I saw a horse from
Gainesville Florida stomp an alligator
on the head on YouTube yeah that sounds
yeah that sounds a horse wouldn't a
horse wouldn't put up with that well a
horse doesn't have to put up with that
they're like no no no yeah I saw a video
of an alligator coming out of a lake in
it was in Florida I don't know where and
a little kitty a little black Kitty like
ran right at him and jumped on his head
was like no yeah and then like ran away
and the alligator was like what and then
he went went back in the
water that cat was not having it yeah
but she just like jumped right on his
head like pow yeah I that one yeah yeah
you
Su yeah Danny said I've seen man-sized
fish swimming around in abandoned
quaries where people would swim and [__]
that yeah yeah pretty much I'm not I'm
not swimming around with any animal
that's big enough to eat me no thanks
yeah it's things like catfish no thanks
um even if they don't eat you they could
drag you underwater and you would drown
yeah and then have other things kind of
like a yeah aropa kill a lot of people
yeah strike them they hit you in the
chest jump out of the water and hit you
in the chest it kills you yep because
it's big animal yeah and they can move
fast and they're [__] like that they
like [__] fly out of the water
[__] hit you right in the chest it
kills you wonder if they're like down
under the water going hey I'm going to
get that one right there they computed
the energy it's the same as being hit
full force with a [__] Sledgehammer
right in your [__] solar plexus pleus
and it will kill you yep yeah some
people have gotten killed like which is
a ridiculous way to die yeah but but
they aim for you they do yeah Pur
they're [__] fish are
[__] And Justice For Me said what's
crazy is the Greenland shark how do they
live for centuries yeah that's the thing
they don't really know I don't really
think they know how long sharks live
either there's no reason that people
should buy die at 80 and 90 they're
looking at that they said aging is in
humans aging is like an error an error
they believe that they believe that they
should be able to correct it
but I'll tell you what if they figured
it out they're not going to tell you
there only going to be very rich people
know about that because they can't have
people that can live 300 years well I'm
sitting there thinking well it'd be nice
to live that long but then I'm just kind
of like man I'm just going to have to
make money and work all that time [__]
that y you know be nice if I was like a
billionaire but other than that it's
just like oh boy 300 more years of like
struggling to pay bills sounds great um
yeah High Desert said I used to go to
catfish restaurants in Oklahoma they
were good although spiny yeah yeah yeah
I really like catfish but yeah you have
to kind of prepare it right though you
got know how to cook them yeah uh he
said remember all those killer bee
movies from the 1970s yeah that was a
whole thing like the Swarm was kind of
the biggest one but there was also there
was a British one called the deadly bees
that was on mst3k which actually isn't
bad it was a moral Panic they were
having Africanized honey bees moving in
so racist yeah well the Africanized
honey bees were killing all the regular
honey bees
yeah and that's probably already
happened by now now now although like I
said I think it was like a lot of things
back then I think it was exaggerated
exaggeration bro yeah I think it was an
exaggeration all right let's go back to
the next one all right so uh we talked
about a bear so now let's talk about
some big cats cuz I kind of feel
like most of the
maneaters um the famous maneaters that
have like really high body counts going
to say the largest percentage of them
are big cats lion tigers uh there's a
leopard in here but they they seem to be
the ones with uh with the highest body
counts so let's talk about the Lions of
nambe now this happened in Tanzania in
1932 now the crazy thing about this
situation was that this was not just one
lion that decided hey humans are
delicious I'm going to snack on them it
was a whole pride of lions that decided
it was going to start eating
people not entirely sure
why uh so the legend was at the time
like when this first started happening
the villagers thought that the lions
were being controlled by uh the local
tribes Witch Doctor whose name was
mamula mag mangera I think was his name
because they had kicked him out of his
post as witch doctor and they're like oh
he's mad at us so he decided he was
going to settle these Lions afterward
now I mean obviously that's silly but
the Lions did kill a [__] ton of people
so you you can forgive them for like
thinking that maybe that was the reason
because you know what would the reason
be otherwise so basically yeah so these
Lions would just come into the village
and just like [__] eat people and
like what are you going to do it's a
whole [__] pride of lions right so
they just come in the village they're
eating people people got so scared of
them they wouldn't even like they
thought there was something like
Supernatural going on so they would talk
about them because they thought if we
talk about them they'll show up like
[__] candy you know what I mean speak
right it's like yeah it was like that
like they thought it was like some kind
of black magic like I said they thought
it was the it was the witch doctor doing
it so they kept attacking now they think
that this pride of
lions killed between this is crazy 1500
and 2,000 people in this time period
damn which is crazy so this might be
actually the worst animal like animal
tax ever then it was a bunch of lions I
mean it wasn't like just one it was a
whole culture of e people they were
learning it from each other right
they're a lot smarter than you think
they learned by experience they see
another they see one of their one of
their friends do it then they do it yeah
yeah so maybe yeah 1500 people 2,000
people they're not entirely sure how
many they killed cuz this was in 1932
but that's still that's a [__] lot
yeah um now eventually some of the lions
were killed by
named George rushby now he killed 15 of
the Lions I don't know how many total
were in The Pride um but it was more it
was substantially more than 15 but he
did manage to kill 15 of the Lions uh at
which point the rest of the pride were
like okay I guess it's getting too hot
around here so we got to move on
somewhere else I don't know where they
went after that but they all they left
after that point but they had to kill 15
of them to do it so um the villagers
though decided anyway they were going to
give the witch doctor his job back just
in case yeah you know what I mean just
so why didn't they try that first yeah
I'm not really sure why okay I'm not
really sure why but uh but yeah so that
was that was kind of a famous like I
said [__] 2,000 people holy crap now
somebody brought this up earlier this is
also lions and this is very famous
because they made a movie about it in
1996 called The Ghost and the Darkness
um the reason the movie was called that
was because that's what they called the
two lions now they talked about this on
The Unexplained the William chatner show
that we saw now this happened in
1898 and the British had started um
building a Railway Bridge over a river
the Sabo River in
Kenya now over the next nine
months the people working on this
railroad started getting attacked by two
manting Lions uh they later found out
that the two of them were
brothers I like that they kind of showed
when they did the reenactment on the
William Shatner show they actually
showed them correctly as the they were
male lions but they didn't have Mains
because this particular breed of lion
that's like from around this area the
males don't have Mains cuz I thought
that was weird too cuz I was like why
and I think in the movie they had Mains
though but they don't looks better on
camera I guess so I guess so but they
didn't actually like in real life so
they said what would happen at first was
that the two lions would come into the
camp at night when everyone was sleeping
and they would drag people out from
their tents and then just drag them into
the surrounding Bush land and eat
them um But as time went on they started
getting more bold I guess and then they
would just come in and just like take
him a little bit out of the tent and
then just start eating them right there
like in front of everybody um you know
what I mean they wouldn't even drag him
in of the
bushes and again just like in the prior
case of the Lions of nambe um because
this was happening like a lot of Natives
and stuff like around the area thought
that these were not actually Lions but
there was something Supernatural going
on like maybe they were possessed by
demons or something like that um one of
the things one of the stories that they
had about it was that the lions were
reincarnations of local King who were
trying to get the British out of the
area yeah makes sense makes total sense
well because apparently that's kind of a
thing in Kenya like or in that part of
Africa and Eastern Africa that um that
Kings can be reincarnated as lions so I
guess that wasn't as weird as it kind of
seems like At first blush you know what
I mean so um so as I mentioned these two
lions were called they named them The
Ghost and the
Darkness and not surprisingly a lot of
the workers on this railroad were like
[__] this [__] uh I quit and they
[__] left so like hundreds of them
left cuz you know every night like the
lions were coming into the into the
village and like just dragging people
out of their tents and eating them you
know what I mean this is the one was was
this the one that was following the uh
the railroad crew yeah is this yeah yeah
this is a railro he was just pick they
were just picking him off yeah they were
just picking him off word of this was
like getting back to England and it was
in the newspapers all the time that they
had to stop stop the building of the
railroad because some dudes got eaten
and
there all these amazing Figures were
coming out like you know five guys got
eaten this week and people back in in
England weren't sure if this was true I
think even the king the king of England
I think was question asked questions
about it didn't he like is this real is
this they sent somebody down yeah it
sounds they sent somebody down there and
verified say no the [__] lions are
eating oh it absolutely happened yeah it
was eating uh these two it was two lions
and they would just come in and they'd
be like hey snacks in tents yeah they
just kept dragging people out and eating
them like I said a lot of people quit
yes the king of England England
suspected it was just fake news yeah
that exists ex like I said that existed
back then it was worse back then like I
said people [__] about it now but it
was way worse back then and there was
like no way to check anything either it
would just totally make up a [__]
story but this absolutely this
absolutely did happen yeah um now what
ended up happening like after a bunch of
people got eaten was that the chief
engineer on the project uh who was a
dude named John Henry Patterson he's
like well we have to find somebody that
that will kill these Lions um he
actually almost got killed by the Lions
himself he got attacked but he got away
um but he ended up shooting one of them
so so he's you know he stepped up he
actually ended up shooting one of them
and then uh two weeks after that he
actually got the second one by the time
that they were shot they had
killed 140 people 140 railroad workers
worked them over yep just drag them out
and ate them y um they also were able to
track where the Lions had been staying
they had like a cave like that they'd
been sleeping and they've been living in
and uh reportedly they found a bunch of
human remains and some like torn up
clothing and stuff like that in there
which is nice and some other [__] that
they drag back from like the other
people's tents which is pretty
maab um I think the cave is still there
I don't know if there's still like Bones
and [__] in there but that's like kind
of [__] up and the thing about it and
I think they said
on somebody mentioned that that just in
the um in the chat just now um big cats
will sometimes kill just for sport
apparently and they think that was maybe
the case with these Lions because they
killed a lot of people but they didn't
eat all of them so they were thinking
that maybe they were just killing them
for shits and
giggles you know um or they got got
Disturbed maybe they were going to eat
it well they'll kill things and then
they'll hide a kill yeah let it soften
let it soften up and come back a few
days later usually they hide in a tree
though yeah where nothing else can get
it CU these ones I think they did eat or
like partially eat some of the people
but some of them they just dragged out
and killed them and then they didn't eat
them yeah now I think I think what it is
it was a Kill by opportunity and then
they stash it and they go we'll go back
and eat this later when we get hungry
yeah because you
they're kind of like an ambush Predator
kind
of so a target of opportunity comes by
well I'm not hungry now but I'll be
hungry later on maybe tomorrow so i'll
kill this one now I'll eat him tomorrow
I'll Stow him over there over lat snack
right that's probably what they're
doing and then maybe sometimes they
never come back to they can't come back
it's sometimes it's kind of like when
you go to the grocery store and you buy
a bunch of produce and then you don't
end up using it well other things happen
and they have to follow you know what I
mean like the group moves
yeah like well there no time to go back
now and go eat that guy that we got
stored we got to follow them the group
we'll just find a new guy to yeah we'll
just get to eat a new
one which is [__] up but you know it's
like they they got to eat too it's like
it's not like a moral question for them
but it's still like pretty messed up if
you're on the other end of that so yeah
so they made the movie The Ghost in the
darkness about this um as somebody
mentioned somebody mentioned that um
yeah cuz their pelts are actually in the
Chicago uh The Field Museum of Chicago
and they said they went up there and see
them I saw a video of a guy basically
getting eaten by lions you uh you can
find it
online dude jumps into the lion habitat
at a zoo I don't remember if it was
China or India might have been
China and he jumps into into the habitat
with a bunch of I think they were I
think they were African lions and he
walks right up to one there's definitely
something wrong with the guy well yeah
and then I think he starts pleading with
it making hands gestures that lon's
looking likee don't like what the [__]
yeah the lion is like he like another m
l comes next to they looking at this guy
what what's this dude doing in here then
what I'm like well [__] this he just
[__] knocked the dude over and
grabbed him by his head you are now my
GrubHub order yeah his whole [__]
mouth covered his head he screamed and
it just started walking with him it ran
with him up out of the view of the
camera and you could hear him screaming
for for a few seconds and then that was
it I mean what did that dude think was
going to happen I think he's had some
kind it was either suicide or he had
some kind of mental problem something
like that but man if you're going to do
that it's like if you're going to off
yourself like there's probably way
better ways to do it than that but they
killed him I don't they probably didn't
have time to eat him because you know
the the the staff was going crazy yeah
everybody's like oh my God that was on
him though man he jumped down the line
yeah that's kind of his fault you know
it's kind of a different thing like if
you fell in there like accidentally or
something like that it's just like he
just went in there deliberately then
you're kind of you can find an edited
version of it on YouTube I mean don't
jump into a lion inclusion yeah go up
and try to talk with them he's look he's
talking with them and he starts pleading
you know if I could talk to the animal
yeah he thought he was Dr pleading with
pleading with the animal doing this and
moving a lot you know and think he had
his jacket in his
hand it's just [__] crazy he probably
Li was like what the [__] is
this yeah like [__] this I'm going eat
the other one standing next to the other
line there's two of them standing side
by side they're looking at each other
like what the [__]
I guess we eat this you know yeah it's
like well he's not he didn't belong in
here just grabbed him by the head he's
like at least if we eat him he'll shut
up yeah yeah screamed like a woman I
mean didn't even scream like a man
screamed like a woman most people
probably would if they were getting
scream I scream like a man screamed like
a woman high pitch we'll see you get
eaten by a Lon then you'll see what
we high pitched woman scream came out of
him Danny says hippo versus Grizzly who
would win
hippo probably hippo sheer Mass always
wins in [__] high desert said hippos
look kind of derpy even though they're
dangerous yeah they're very dangerous
probably why there are no killer hippo
hippo movies yeah and then like below
that be that bison it's one of those
yeah you wouldn't hippos like I said
they look so cute and they're all fat
and everything and it's like they look
kind of friendly and there's cartoons of
them but it's like they are they will
absolutely [__] your [__] up they're
mean and they're intelligent tremendous
bite
force just Crush you with those big
[__] teeth teeth are like flat molers
like bricks they just just Crush you
they swallow you one of my favorite
hippo facts is like one thing that they
like to do is they is they poop in the
water and then like they swish their
tail like that to make the water all
poopy yeah for whatever for whatever
reason yeah I think that's why you can't
see me yeah it's my [__]
screen I don't know why that's like
funny to me but I'm just kind of like
that's super disgusting but yeah that's
what they do yeah it was Injustice for
me that said when I was a kid I saw the
two lions on display in Chicago yeah
they because they were like uh pretty
famous so um what okay so the thing
about it they mentioned this on the
William Shatner show that when they
killed the Lions one of them was injured
right like its tooth was broken or
impacted or something like that so they
suspected that one of them because it's
tooth was broken and it couldn't hunt
its normal prey anymore it all infected
that it started you know waned to go
after like you know softer easier
targets which would be humans and
apparently talked his brother into
helping him out and then I guess like
the brother was just kind of like hey
these guys are pretty delicious okay
this is a good plan you got going here
cuz humans are much easier to eat than
their regular I don't think he talked
him into I think they were just a pair
they grew up together yeah they were
they were brothers like one one of them
started eating humans and the other one
just followed goes yeah you can eat
these too he's like yeah they're they're
also made of meat and they don't run
fast so it's easy and they don't have
any horns and they don't have any
anything they don't have any armor yeah
there's not much meat either so they
just eat more of them yeah it's like but
there's a whole bunch of them and
they're just laying there they're just
laying out on the ground that's how
they're you can just pick them up it's
like being at a Chinese buffet yeah just
eat more of them like little dumplings
just like laying there it's like you
know you know like humans don't really
think themselves in those terms but
that's what you look like to a wild
animal you just look like a nice soft
little dumpling laying out there on the
ground yeah people don't understand
nature everything nature is about
animals trying to kill each other even
even plants are trying to kill each
other some indirectly and and directly
some of them are some of them are like
[__] parasites feeding on other
plants other ones are just trying to out
compete the other plant next to them
with making by choking out the root
system and stealing more nutrients and
more stealing more
sunlight everything is is either eating
things or gonna be eaten by something
so nature is about murder really they're
all killing each other yep and they
don't really see it that way they're
just kind of like hey I'm trying just
trying to survive eat yeah food yeah
they're everything they eat is they're
denying food from to something else
because they ate it and another animal
didn't so everything imposes like I said
part of the nian
philosophy that they're we're all
guilty we all impose on everything yeah
I mean you can't help it you can't you
can't help it well even Buddha there
sartha Goa the original Buddha said the
same thing he says just by existing
you're imposing okay because you have to
eat things you're breathing air just you
know I mean other people have to feed
you if you get too old he says the
ultimate the ultimate uh state of being
is to not impose to be totally you know
you have no footprint on the earth that
means die that's what he did he he
starved himself that's why they would
show him as fat he was fat with wisdom
but they if that guy really existed I'm
not sure if sidarth the Goa actually
existed or if he was I kind of doubt it
probably a composite of a bunch of
that's what I that's what I thought I
thought um if that dude did live
according to the stories though he was
an old man when he did that so yeah he's
just like ah [__] he lived his life yeah
yeah let me me uh go oh drinky time make
drink High Desert said imagine living in
prehistoric times you would have no gun
or even bows and arrows all you'd have
was a club yeah must have sucked hard
that's probably why they didn't live all
that long back then I mean they didn't
know any different so I guess it
wouldn't be that bad but still yeah if I
had a time machine I'm definitely not
going back anytime like that actually if
I had a time machine I don't think I
would go back into the past at all you
know what I mean maybe for like a day or
two but nah no thanks especially not
before there was like flush toilets or
electricity or anything like that I
don't think so I don't think so that
doesn't sound like any fun at all all
right so uh so we have some other
another story of a big cat now this
wasn't the only uh manaing
leopard there were several of them in
generally around in India but this one
was the most famous and I believe had
the highest body count this is the panar
leopard now leopards are actually of the
of all the big cats they are the
smallest but um again they will still
[__] up your day and there are several
examples of man-eating
ones so um the thing about it too is
that they think that leopards are
probably one of
humans oldest Predators like they've
found you know ancient homed bones that
have like leopard tooth marks on them so
obviously they were eating humans going
way back you know what I
mean so um I mean they generally don't
become it's a lot of animals don't
become specific maneaters in the sense
of yeah they'll eat a person if there's
a person there and they're hungry but
it's very rare for an animal to
specifically Target humans to eat you
know what I mean but there have been a
few and several of them are
leopards so the worst man eating leopard
of all time was as I said the panar
leopard now this was a male leopard and
this was in a particular region of India
called um cumon cumon I don't know if
I'm pronouncing that correctly uh this
was like early part of the 20th
century now uh he's called The panar
Leopard because you know the place that
he was that was the panar province that
was where he killed most of his uh
victims he is thought to have killed at
least as far as they know over four 400
people making this leopard the second
most prolific Maneater in recorded
history now again it seems like this is
a very common thing among
maneaters they believe that this leopard
had been injured somehow by a hunter
shot or hit with an arrow or something
like that um and the injury was such
that it couldn't hunt its normal prey
anymore so it decided it was going to
start eating nice soft little people
because it's
easier so like I said I kind of feel
like that's a pretty common Trope
especially with the big
cats that they they get injured somehow
and can't hunt you know zebra or Caribou
or whatever it is that they normally
hunt and so they're like ah well we
don't like these little pink things like
running around but they're easy to catch
I guess so they'll just like eat those
now this leopard um as I said as far as
they know it killed over 400 people it
was eventually killed um in
1910 by Jim Corbett now we're going to
talk more about Jim Corbett because this
[__] he probably needs an entire
show like all his own because and it's
funny because when I said that we were
doing a show about this somebody came on
and said please tell me you're going to
talk about Jim Corbett um and I was like
yeah I am cuz he killed
several of the world's worst man-eating
animals um so he's kind of a badass you
know what I mean and he was the one that
killed the panaro leopard matter of fact
what year was this again this was um
early 20th century okay so you know what
I mean 1900s 1910 he killed the Panara
leopard that's when this kind of
Adventure was still available early
1900s yeah I mean I guess it's still
around nowadays because there's still
man eting animals around nowadays cuz
we're going to talk about Gustav later
the crocodile early 1800s was cool
because back in those days you could
actually you weren't sure that things
like gorillas act were re were a reality
they they thought that was a
mythological
creature um they thought that maybe
there were Islands out there that might
have [__] dinosaurs on them because
because they didn't have satellite
photography so you might just find an
island that's just like [__] it it's got
brosaurus on it you know you don't know
anything was possible in the early 1900s
you couldn't Pro you know they didn't
know they didn't know what was in the
Amazon they now they know from you know
all the Myster is gone yeah all the
mystery's gone I don't think that's true
satellites can
see but to a large extent yeah here
here's something very
interesting satellites can now see
Subterranean ruins all over South and
Central America yeah you can't see them
on the surface because there's Fields
over them right where they're planted or
just or trees and [__] A lot of times
they're underneath Farms but there were
massive cities
kind of like the like the Inca and the
Aztec and all that throughout all that
and there seems to be some in
Amazon that's that's incredible just far
away from any modern habitats I kind of
feel like if you know what I feel like
if I had another lifetime like to go
back to school and stuff like that I
would love to get
into all of the [__] about meso America
like all the cities and [__] like that
that were there because I feel like
there's so much there that people don't
know about yeah because it's in the
united all the archaeologists are
interested in damn Europe and ancient
Egypt I get that that's that's where
kind of where the glamour is classic
Antiquity that's where they all want but
they're not even looking at the United
States there's [__] ancient ruins all
over the United States [__] there's
weird [__] here though they don't know
what the [__] it is and the
mississippians the mississippians not
not me but there was a Miss
Mississippian civilization it was
Alabama Mississippi
Louisiana uh and Tennessee that area
there was ruins there you can see them
through satellite
now but uh and know we're
talking seven8 10,000 15,000 years you
know that Graham Hancock [__] [__]
you know there were Earth pyramids and
but the more they kind channels and
[__] the more they look into it I
feel like
finding like massive cities and [__]
like that in meso America that they
didn't even know existed like 20 30
years ago which is crazy yeah like that
were just as big or bigger than anything
that was in like comparable stuff from
Europe at the time yeah which is
fascinating and it's like I would love
to get in on the ground floor a lot of
people don't know history they
definitely don't know like Mexican
history they don't teach it and it sucks
man it's like I even grew up like you
know I grew up in Florida and I got a
decent Ed education and they mostly
focus on European history like I think
we did a chapter on Florida history and
like we talked about that um you know
obviously had a couple classes in
American history but they don't really
talk about even when they talk about
ancient history because I had a couple
classes in that too they don't really go
much into they don't really go much into
meso America they don't talk about Asia
much either I'd really recommend reading
a book that has excerpts of hernand
Cortez's [__] reports
back to Spain and his description of
what was happening with the Aztec and
the other uh Indians that the Aztec had
basically forced to pay
tribute a lot of people don't realize it
but when the Spaniards showed up and
Cortez wasn't the first guy that showed
up I think the first two missions those
dudes never came back because they they
mutinied when they saw a May City or an
Aztec city they were [__] petrified
because they were bigger than anything
in Europe and they were painted
according to Cortez in red and turquoise
paint with huge baskets the size of
three-story buildings filled with heads
skulls human sacrifices they had open
cannibalism happening I mean I would
[__] myself too if hug and these were
huge advanced cities with Advanced
knowledge and and literature and number
system and their version of Technology
they uh were up there with ancient Egypt
all right yeah it was 1500s but they had
been that way for thousands of years
yeah I just feel know much about it
right you know what I mean and it was
all erased over time by the church the
Catholic church because they they had to
they wanted to replace the Aztec gods
with Christianity which was actually
very similar to the Aztec gods yeah it's
not that different really no the the the
Aztecs converted easily because they're
like all right close enough yeah they
were like every every icon in Catholic
in the Catholic religion with their
Saints and Virgin Mary and there was
kind of an Aztec equivalent to that they
were very similar well as I mentioned
human brains are they only have so many
I mean they're amazing but there's only
so many ways they can go only so many
channels they can go down so usually
even if there's cultures that are a
world apart and have never had any
contact with one another you will find
some similarities in their belief
systems it's just because that of the
limitations of like human imaginations
they come up with the same [__] given
the same circumstances you know those
Aztecs were [__] smart they had one
of the most advanced calendars and an
advanced number system that we haven't
really figured out until recently um
they could do mathematics they could do
all kinds of stuff with they were doing
mathematics and and evidentally
primitive or the beginning parts of
algebra but they didn't even have the
Arabic numeral system they they used a
different system but pretty sure they
didn't have zero either did they no I
think they did say that they had zero
maybe they did that it was the it they
think that they did have zero which
which is quite a concept of the number
zero but uh they could do computations
they they what was what's sad is that
all their records were burned they
burned them all yeah and there
were um Spanish Friars that had learned
or monks that had learned learned all
this stuff they were sending letters
back to the pope saying look you can't
destroy this knowledge there's there's a
lot of literature and stuff here these
people you know you can't let this stuff
be lost and he they were writing books
and sending it back to the to the
Catholic Church to the Vatican and try
to preserve as much as possible it still
exists those books exist but they're
they're all in the Vatican yeah they let
people see
them but most of the information about
That civilization it was and most of it
that survived was in the hands of the
Vatican uh but they couldn't they
couldn't they couldn't said uh save it
all Dresden Codex codex they saved
that what had to do with the calendar
was the central yeah we're talking about
Mexico now okay good I was going to say
that um you might actually like to I'm
not sure about now but years ago I went
to uh this I think it's the south
Florida Museum in Tampa St Pete and they
have a huge Mesoamerican collection in
there they have some cool [__] yeah when
you're talking about there's no such
thing as primitive civilizations they're
all about the same those people
were just as intelligent as us they had
just had different traditions and
different religions that would but they
were basically like like modern people
of today uh sanitation was good um an
ancient Roman could go there and he'd
trip out on a lot of stuff but they you
know but they were as advanced as say
Romans and Romans were pretty [__]
Advanced we didn't start thinking like
Romans until the early
1900s I think I think the Romans were
basically kind of mentally ahead of
people in the 1800s Romans were a lot
more worldly lot more sophisticated yeah
High Desert said the Portland Zoo had
videos of their baby hippo who looked
very friendly probably not so much now
yeah yeah baby hippos are super super
cute but yeah hippos are dicks they will
[__] you you up yeah so yeah so we're
talking about leopards yeah and we were
talking about Jim Corbett so even though
the panar leopard which was shot by uh
by Jim Corbett is the uh most famous and
the one with the highest body count like
I said he killed 400 people uh there
were more than one leopard in India at
the time that killed a bunch of people
there was another one called the Kahani
Maneater uh who killed about 200 people
and there was another one called the I'm
sure I'm pronouncing this wrong but the
rro prayag
Maneater his thing was that um there
would be like all of these pilgrims that
were going to this Hindu Shrine in the
area and he would like wait like lie and
wait and when they were going to the he
would attack him and kill him so he
killed about 125 people that one was
also killed by Jim Corbett because like
I said Jim Corbett was like yeah one of
those dudes what back in the old days
when you know everyone was fascinated by
like Adventure and Feats of Daring Do
and all that um yeah he would go out
there he was the dude you called it's
like we have this man eating whatever
and you need to come out here and like
solve this problem he'd be like I'm on
it and he would come out there and kill
him he killed like a bunch of man eating
animals that's actually normal Ambush
Predator Behavior they know the migr the
migratory uh habits of of prey so people
walk into Temple yeah he knew that
timing he knew when they were coming
he's just like yeah you right here
they're going to walk by all these
little pink snacks are going to be
walking right by there I'm going to jump
right on them
yep um now according to some talking
about lepin even though they are
significantly smaller than lions or
tigers um they are thought to be more
agile and maybe
smarter um so basically a lot of people
that hunted them or that knew about them
thought that they were maybe more
dangerous and one of them even said if
the leopard was the size of a lion it
would be 10 times more dangerous than a
lion um now Jim Corbett also said
something about leopards cuz he had
killed some man eting tigers as well
which we'll get into in a bit but um
they said he said at least in his
opinion or his experience he said tigers
usually become maneaters because
something happens to them like they get
an illness or an injury or something
like that that prevents them from
hunting their regular prey and so they
start hunting people in his experience
he found that leopards became became
maneaters after they had scavenged on
human
corpses implying that they had developed
a taste for human flesh well they they
he learned that you could eat them yeah
yeah so that's that's kind of
interesting yeah so yeah so let's talk
about this Jim Corbett dude for a minute
uh because somebody asked me to kind of
go into it now he was actually he's born
in 1875 died in 1955 uh he was actually
born in India but he was British um
Hunter tracker later naturalist and he
wrote a bunch of books as well and like
I said he hunted he was kind of the guy
that you went to for hunting Ming Tigers
mostly tigers and leopards um and mostly
around India he was a colonel in the
British Indian army and like I said he
was the guy that you called you know
what I mean um and he wrote a whole
bunch of books about it the funny thing
about it though is that even though he
killed all these man eating tigers and
leopards or whatever later on in his
life he actually stopped hunting and
became a photographer and became a
conservationist um saying that we have
to protect India's Wildlife you know
from uh being exterminated which is kind
of funny because that's he spent his
entire career exter but I mean he was
Exterminating them because they were
eating people which actually some of the
greatest contributors to conservation
are the are Hunters yeah because they
understand the balance of nature you
know what I mean that if you take
animals you got to make sure that you're
creating more animals uh so you my dad
did that too you know fing on the land
that he had hunting rights on you plant
stuff that deers eat and you let them
grow in large numbers on your on your
claim uh and then you just cull off the
top um so it's kind of like having cows
in a pasture except they can come and go
they're they're they're wild you're just
trying to attract them by planting
things now you can't bait them you you
mean you can't leave food out that game
wardens will get you for that but you
can plant Ry grass that they like Ry
grass you can plant acorn trees they eat
those but you're never the idea is not
to hunt the animal out if you hunt them
out then you don't have you're out of
food you're trying to get them to breed
it become
numerous um because this is happening in
Mississippi you know what I'm talking
about and um it's it's it's rural
and um it can support a lot of deer but
so can it the suburbs can support deer
too [__] we moved out of a [__]
high-end suburb it was filled with
[__] deer see deer all the time like
pets yeah I'd be out on the I'd be out
walking on the on the jogging trail out
there and it's like hey what's up deer
they just be walking across the [__]
deer can thrive in [__] they're all
over the place in human OCC one was
sitting in our backyard one time they'll
thrive in a suburb cuz people aren't
hunting them yeah they can just hang
it's not a hunting area CU everybody's
like oh dear now I've seen people freak
out on on um Facebook when somebody
shoots a lion or uh some kind of big
African game but they don't understand
what's
happening in those African
Parks the numbers of those animals are
controlled because it's no longer it's
now the modern world those Parks can
only support so many animals they know
what the footprint of that animal is so
when the lion population starts to get
too
big the park rangers allow guys to pay
to come in and cull off the oldest Lions
to make room for the new ones that have
have been born so people don't realize
that you know what I mean
[__] they think well that's an
endangered animal yeah it's endangered
but it but that was under a highly
controlled thing they've killed off one
the old ones and in nature they die when
they get to that age anyway you know cuz
they're living longer than they did
because uh it's the place isn't as wild
as it was anymore it's kind of like a
park yeah
so they know how many animals the
environment can
support they're not going to let that
those Hunters go in there and shoot them
all just a couple then the money that
they that those Hunters had to pay to
Cull those Lions now goes back to the
park to pay the park rangers and to help
protect the it's all part of the the
balance Nature's Balance you know you
can't have too many lines or they're all
starve because they'll eat all the damn
gazel there's not enough of them you
know they know what they're doing it's
unfortunate but that's the way nature is
nature is everything trying to kill each
other yeah which like I said it's you
don't really like to see that I don't
like to see that yeah you like man he
had to kill that night
yeah but they can't have have too many
lions or there's not enough I mean you
can't really have any too much of
anything well like I said that's kind of
the thing where you know sometimes you
get into a situation where an animal
gets introduced into environment where
they're not native and then they kind of
take over yeah and then it's just like
you got to kind of have to kill them
yeah even if they're cute um and you
know to like happened in Australia with
all the bunnies and stuff like that and
it's like nobody wants to have to kill
like cute little bunny rabbits but
that's their job in nature is to be
eaten that's why they reproduce so much
and the thing about it is that if you
have too many of one thing they're going
to [__] up the whole they [__] up this
balance the whole ecosystem yeah you
know what I mean yeah so
um another thing is is that Lions Tigers
and the big cats are endangered in the
wild but overall they're not endangered
because there's a [__] ton of those in
captivity I mean remember the [__]
Lion King whatever that dude there's a
lot lots of those places there's one
three miles from here yeah we have one
like right by our fill with [__]
lions and tigers he's probably got 40 of
them yeah he's got a bunch yeah they you
can breed them and people have them like
pets in certain countries walking around
inside the damn living room I mean here
you have to have a certain license but
LIC but that guy has he has like a bit
huge enclosure with like big huge
concrete walls and stuff yeah so those
endangered animals like those African
animals they're endangered in the wild
but they they won't ever go extinct
because people own
them they got them
weird but but the thing is is that even
ancient Egyptians and ancient Romans
kept Lions as pets they make good pets
I've seen videos of them in people's
homes in India and [__] I mean playing
with the children and everything the
thing about it like you follow that
channel where they have it's not a lion
it's a is it a panther Puma it's a puma
yeah the Russian guy that has a puma and
a and a and a black panther a that's
right it's not a puma it's a it's an
American Mountain line oh okay it's
Mountain L which is a which is a type of
puma and he loves that man
he with him and sits there and just
you're like man that's dangerous thing
is is that animal grew up with those
people he takes it outside got it on a
leash it puts clothes on it because it's
cold it's Russia insulated jacket lets
him
play Messi is his name name of the
Chanel is I am Puma yeah you'll see him
him and his wife they gets up in the bed
sleeps with them they make good pets
which like I said you know the thing
about it is that I think people would be
like well yeah but it could eat your
face off but I'm like well a big dog
could eat your face off y so kill you
yeah they dog yeah it's a good dog then
like or a Rottweiler or something like
that so I mean you or just a regular dog
like [__] um when I was younger we had a
neighbor that had a German shepherd and
it was a nice dog we used to see it all
the time one day it ran like my little
brother when he was maybe three he was
just sitting in the yard minding his own
business in that um and that German
sheer ran across at it and tried to
attack him yeah just no reason yeah you
would think well man if that lion got
out it would eat people no not really
that those lions and lions that are hand
raised by people just kind of like dogs
a dog could go out escape and kill a
person but the LI Lion's not that much
different um but no they're real
friendly just walk up to people hey how
you doing lay down real chill that'd be
super cool
like they've been do it's been happening
for thousands of years Romans had them
walking around in Roman Palace well like
I said if you rais it from a baby yeah
don't see humans as food and it wouldn't
see you as like a snack they've never
hunted anything they've always been fed
yeah so they don't have to yeah I mean I
wouldn't trust it completely still
because you know it might still have
instinctual things where it's like man
I'm kind of hungry I think eat her most
educated experts now that have spent
time with all these animals say they're
exactly like domestic house cats it's
the same thing the only difference is
the size differential yeah well I've
always known that domestic cats like pet
are pretty much just like cuz I always
thought like if Pooky was Lion's eyes
she would probably eat my face big time
they won't they
won't no she probably wouldn't cuz she
feeding it cuz I'm mommy but you know
your mommy and feeding it they have
neony child they because they're like a
domesticated
animal because they were been raised
around people they see people as as
somebody who gives them food and takes
care of them they don't eat
people I guess and people pet them you
know so it's different situation they're
not wild that's why a lion will sit
right there and have fun with a house
cat and a dog and a chicken and a monkey
and won't won't eat any of them cuz it's
always been fed got it all on video
we're all just hanging out you can see
video of it I love videos of like cross
species friendships yeah that's so cute
to me yeah one of my favorite ones was
like this friendship that I saw between
a cat and I think it was a raven or an
owl maybe it was two different ones that
I'm thinking of but yeah they were like
best buds yeah pretty chill if they're
raised around people their personality
is pretty chilled
out Oscar says why is it that whenever
you hear of a dog attack on a human it's
a Pitbull it's never a rer German
Shepherd St Bernards except except Kujo
dogs are even larger than pites yeah it
really and I kind of feel like Pit's got
like a really bad reputation for a while
to a point now where like a lot of
apartment complexes and stuff like that
won't even allow you to have that breed
but I don't know I think that that
dog I think some of it was media
fear-mongering um and I think some of it
was the fact that that dog was
a little bit like maybe bread for
fighting I don't know I'm kind of more
scared of Rottweilers than I am of pites
because Rottweilers are like really big
and the thing about it was that I used
to know my
ex-husband's cousin somebody like
somebody in his family they had a
massive Rottweiler like as a pet and I
went over there to the house and the
[__] dog was huge and it was like
[__] terrifying and it was like
really aggressive you know what I mean
and I think a lot of people had
them for that reason because they were
like really big aggressive dogs and they
thought that was cool or whatever so I
don't know I'm kind of more scared of
those cuz pit bulls aren't very big I've
never known anybody that had a pitbull
actually but but like I said when I was
younger a German Shepherd did attack my
brother like my little brother when he
was little didn't hurt him but cuz we
kind of intervened but and it was the
neighbor's dog and they'd had that dog
like forever I don't really know why
well pit BS attack because people were
beaten up beaten up that's I kind of
feel like the thing about it trying to
make them into fighting dogs if a I
think that's the problem the thing about
it is that domestic
dogs I don't think they will generally
attack people
unless they've been
abused um and that's the only experience
of life that they have yeah or unless a
person is like really [__] with them
problem is dog
fighting they got people that are weird
weird people they are into dog fighting
it's usually ghetto as [__] we need to
stop all dog fighting yeah big time yeah
they use bait dogs and [__] just you
know dogs are not meant for that that's
[__]
stupid they think it's real Macho and
[__] to bet on these
dogs [__] horrible yeah that is like
there is absolutely nothing Macho or
cool about that no at all I don't really
understand where that perception would
come
from World [__] that's just [__]
up half naked you says pit bulls are way
scarier than a German Shepherd pits were
bred to fight dog genetics matter yeah I
think they do to an extent but like I
said it's just like a person genetics is
important but how that dog is treated uh
matters too You Ever Seen The Little
Rascals remember the dog [__]
py remember the dog that was a pitbull
that's right he was wasn't he yeah it
was a pitbull pitbull has been around
for a long time yeah I well because I
feel like when people got into the habit
of fighting them later on that cuz I
kind of feel like the whole Pitbull is
killer dog thing that when did that come
about the 90s yeah I kind of feel like
that was maybe like a '90s I think they
always kind of fought them but cuz when
I was little when I was when I was a kid
I remember everybody being scared of
doberman's I remember that being the big
scary killer dog doberman's humans have
a lot of bad habits used to be back in
Europe they would do bear baiting which
is the
tie tie a bear tie a bear's [__] leg
to a chain and put it in a shackle and
then [__] stake it to the ground and
run up and [__] pester the [__] out
of that bear and [__] try to set it
on fire and [__] do to [__]
because it's a bear yeah bear left on
his own is [__] tame pretty tame like
hey I'm not bothering you Jesus Christ
most of them are friendly you know and
they weren't doing that to Savage Bears
they were
just medieval Europe an were [__]
crazy they were psychos it's all that
lead man yeah I mean they did [__] that
only psychos would do yeah big time well
like I said you did that now you do that
nowadays rightfully so people would be
like yeah you're insane and you're going
to jail some people would kill you and
again probably right yeah the right
person sees that they'll kill
you because I mean doing [__] to animals
that's akin to like doing stuff to
people that's how serial killers start
out it's a k to doing it to children
they yeah they do cruel [__] to to
animals like I said I was coming home
from work one night and this is when I
lived in
Daytona somebody on like on a couple
blocks from my house somebody had put a
plastic bag over a cat's head yeah and I
found it yeah and I had like rip a hole
in the bag so the cat could breathe I
couldn't get it off cuz it was like
freaking out and stuff but I ripped a
hole in it so it could breathe yeah but
it's just kind of I was like who the
[__] would do this a cereal killer
that's kid or something a [__] cereal
a potential serial that's who does that
kind of [__] yeah why would you even
think of that i' do that to whoever did
that yeah but that's a human being I
don't if you do me I don't give a [__]
I'm sorry but I don't give a [__] you do
that to an animal or another human I
think you you've revoked your human
being card you you provoked your human
being card at that point next infantry
man 101st [__] Airborne I6 327
[__] I was in the first 327 Recon
look that up it's also know as Tiger
Force [__] most war crimes out of any
unit oh kill you like it's nothing if
I'm mad at
you confirmed yeah and I mean [__] like
confirmed if you piss me off like that
and you're a bad person and [__] I'll
[__] down you yeah cuz they were
asking me to kill people in our not just
me the other guys that worked with me
kill people that were nothing wrong with
them they just wearing the wrong
uniform horrible I will never I will
never
understand sending these guys out I will
never understand people that like serial
killers and stuff like that that have
this compulsion to hurt something little
than them or like weaker than them I
will never understand
inadequacy yeah that's got to be what it
is that never occurs to me it's just
like a horrible horrible yeah and I see
people do that like I said that [__]
that they did that don't [__] with cats
documentary that killed those kittens
and the like sucked all the air out of
the vacuum bag or whatever and that dude
and it's like I need the guy killed his
boyfriend later yeah well and the thing
about it and hoay for the internet
people saw that and they got so [__]
mad they found his ass yeah I would have
[__] that kid up they found his ass
that dude was a [__] piece of [__]
yeah then he ate parts of his boyfriend
and [__] made like who the [__] would do
that it's like that's [__] they start
off killing the animals like that that's
what I mean helpless animals they're
just helpless it's a [__] kitten come
on
yeah you know what this is [__] up but
we go to um like on the weekend
sometimes we go to the books of million
and go to like hang out in the coffee
shop or whatever and a few times a week
they usually have adoption um things for
it's a hoffmire animal rescue right
that's where we got Bambi from yeah and
so they'll set up all the little
enclosures and they have like all these
little kittens they do dogs too but they
usually do them different days so we
were there this past Sunday I think it
was and they had a kitten adoption of
event so they had like all the
enclosures there with kittens and stuff
and all these people are coming in and
like usually we see one or two kittens
get adopted like every time we're there
so that's like really cool but it's
always in the back of my mind because I
read and write about so much True Crime
and I know how horrible these [__]
are I'm always like really worried that
somebody in that crowd is just going to
come up and do something to one of those
kittens like before they can stop him
it's like in the back of my mind there
though is but I just I can't help
thinking those D that do that to those
animals are doing it in private because
there's usually some kind of weird
sexual kind of element to it there was a
video running around I don't know if
they ever caught the guy it's probably
Eastern Europe it was
called I think a one [__] 12 puppies
something like that yeah I remember that
was pretty famous yeah yeah where he
does terrible things to this these
puppies in front of the mama dog then he
kills the mama dog and [__] he vide
vide tape the whole thing and I don't
know if they ever caught the guy they
thought there was it was something they
thought it was something that happened
in one of the Eastern European countries
I hope somebody skinned him alive had
another dude that was got another kid
that was putting cats inside of bird
cages and spilling gas lean over them
and setting them on fire videotaping
that as the cat's
[__] see I can't watch that kind of
stuff like even imagining it just like
keeps that kid head i d that kid's head
[__] gas yeah like how do you like on
fire and see if he how that see how long
that's pretty cool right pretty cool
right yeah not so cool now is it yeah is
I don't give a [__] that you're 14 I'm
setting Your Head On Fire I mean I'm
videotape that look teenagers are stupid
okay everybody knows that but if you're
14 and you're doing [__] like that
you're crazy yeah I think you probably
need to be taken out to jle before you
get even worse yeah get a can of Sterno
there's not paint his whole head with
that [__] damn Sterno cream and set
that on fire cuz there's just no tied up
to a steak I don't really know if
there's any coming back from anything
that extreme at that age no some of them
do that and then they don't go on to
but but it's risk probably better to air
on the side of caution would say yeah
like I said I don't care if you're a kid
or not come on now um but yeah so what
we were talking about okay where were we
U some talking about pit bulls but
somebody got bit by pit bow and this pit
bulls are
sweet what happens with the pit bulls is
that you're going to have these [__]
fake badasses that buy pit bulls and try
to toughen them up and then they're
[__] then that thing's dangerous but
you could do that about any dog well
yeah that's what I mean it's not just
that breed speciic only thing special
about a pitbull is that it's got a very
powerful bite force and once it's got a
hold of you it really can't let go it's
short it's got a real [__] wide front
end on it you know the shoulders pretty
thick but
yeah it can bite but that's not the only
dog that's like that I mean I wouldn't
[__] with a damn regular old American
Bulldog those that's real close you know
and then there's other dogs out there
that I think that
probably probably even worse but if it
if it wanted to kill you but they're
rare they're expensive so pretty much
only rich people have them that's [__]
like the Cane Corso that thing's [__]
huge just the size of a [__] small
bear
no it's a size of a midsize bear huge
hat on
it I haven't seen any numbers on the
bite force on a can Corso but I would
imagine a can Corso could easily kill a
man just by looking at its skull and the
size and uh
man that thing the size of a large
man it's an amazing
dog
somebody says what's up with the sex
creeps from Eastern Europe I don't
know well those they're those guys are
everywhere but Eastern Europe over the
you know past 30 years since the
collapse of the Soviet Union it was kind
of like a wild no man's land for a while
a lot
of lot it wasn't Poss lot of poverty
there's no way to really have [__]
law enforcement and people would grow up
in weird ways since the collapse of
Soviet Union every now and then it was
creating monsters every now and then
just the
environment Danny says the veterinarians
that euthanize animals on a daily on The
Daily are the true emotionless psychos I
don't see you know what when I was a kid
I wanted to be a
veterinarian and then it occurred to me
that that would be a large part of my
job yeah and I'm just kind of like yeah
no there is no way I'd be able to do
that no way I heard that a lot of those
centers they just put all the cages in a
room and Dam run a car [__] tailpipe
into it and just run the car gas them
all that I don't know about that I mean
probably not supp be a cheaper way of
doing it than to give them all lethal
injection but still there's just no way
I can do that I mean I
know carbon monoxide yeah it has to be
done sometimes and everything like that
but it's like I'm not going to be the
person to do it sorry I like animals
what's the next Maneater uh well we
haven't finished talking about the last
one yet okay uh half naked you said it
takes a special kind of low life that
uses a dog to feel tough right yeah yeah
I mean if you're going to be tough just
be tough don't you're get a jamm work
out take some steroids well and I mean
don't be so [__] a bunch of fights yeah
well I don't know if you need to do that
but don't be so [__] try hard about
it oh no get don't be so [__] try
hard about it getting in fights will
make you tough tell about because you're
gonna get your ass beat
[__] in a way it's probably better to
get your ass
beat you know what I mean rather than
going around being like I can beat
everyone's ass
get your ass beat feel feel what that
dudes that [__] want to go around and
beat everybody they want to beat they
want to fight weak guys that's what I'm
saying I kind of feel like generally the
more people talk about how tough they
are the less tough they are the less
tough they are cuz I'm like if you
really like a tough guy you wouldn't
have to like [__] tell everybody
everybody would just know without you
having to say anything so that's why I'm
always like really suspicious of any
kind
of marker like that any kind of like
virtue signaling like that like I have
this big uge truck or have this big
tough dog or something like that I'm
like you have inadequacy issues clearly
so I you know I'm just saying well I
don't know I'm not going to say it's
just the dog and the truck it's just
when you see the dog and you see the
truck and you look at the dude and
there's a big difference then you go I
see what's going on if you can have a
big ass truck like that a big ass dog
when I look at you I better be
impressed they do have some dudes that
are like that I would actually be more
impressed by a dude that was like 65 and
it was like super jacked and everything
like that and he was just driving this
little bitty like electric car cuz he's
like [__] it I don't give a [__] what
people think about me yeah they don't do
that though I know but I'm just saying
I'd be a lot more impressed by that
because he's not trying to impress
anybody see the fact that you're trying
to impress somebody makes me much less
imp electric car you might be you're
trying you may be trying to impress some
of those green chicks though well I
don't it doesn't have to be an electric
car just anything that's seen is like
just a regular car right this just like
a little bitty regular car like a little
bitty one yeah so it's so it's anything
just a [__] hot Civic right like that
is a lot more impress because you're not
trying to impress anybody like I said
the Civic is a great car it is actually
but um it's very reliable very reliable
for doing like a commercial for but um
but yeah I like I said I'm super
suspicious of anybody that tries to
impress people like I said either be the
way you are and everybody would be like
yeah that's cool because if you're if
you're overdoing it then I'm going to
get suspicious I'm gonna get suspicious
that's all I'm
saying um Oscar said uh the kind of dog
that attacked the little girl and went
evil lurks yeah what kind of dog was
that which one was where the the one
that we just watched the other day the
Argentinian one remember the dog and it
chewed that girl's face off oh yeah I
don't remember what kind of dog was that
I think it was a bulldog was it oh I
can't
remember I think it was a bulldog it
might have been but I have to go back
and watch cuz I wasn't I I remember
looking at the dog but I can't remember
like what breed it was
Danny ring said the Honda Civic SI 99 is
the best Civic
ever I never had a Honda Civic I had oh
wait no I did for a little while I had a
Honda Accord for a while and I had a
Toyota
Tel and I had a Nissan Sentra I've had a
lot of Japanese you had Honda Fit you
had I had Honda Fit Honda Fit that the
[__] was good I like that fit was
[__] fast I bought that one new that
was the first new car I ever well the
only new car I've ever bought
I would think overall the best car I
ever owned was a uh late 80s I think it
was a 1986 or I think it was an 86 or an
87 Toyota Corolla SR5
hatchback
yeah that [__] ran and ran and and I
was I was kind of a kid I couldn't
afford to [__] do upkeep on the thing
all I did is change the oil and put
Breck pads on it and tires that thing
[__] ran
forever Corolla SR5 [__] bad car it
was just a [__] mpaw looking car
family car looking thing sometimes
better not to get like some flashy like
[__] because I [__] rock solid I have
right now I have a 2004 For Taurus yeah
it looks like ass looks like [__] it
runs it looks so bad it's silver it's
got like well it's Florida so all the
paint has mostly burned off and it's got
like spots of rust on it and uh [__]
like that but I'll be damned if that
thing doesn't just keep on going hey 700
for it no it wasn't it was yeah there
was 700 we put it was 7 no no we paid
1,400 for it is that included all the
tires no okay, 1400 and then we paid
another 500 okay to put tires and we had
to put a new um I think we had to put a
new coil pack in it yeah I put that in
and a couple other things yeah so it
ended up being like 1900 yeah and that
car was infested with roaches it was oh
yeah that's right I had a bug V it like
several times because they had CT it was
a company car and they had not used it
for a while and so they left garbage in
the trunk that they forgot about garbage
bags so so it was yeah like garbage bags
they put them in there they were going
to dump them somewhere at some point and
I guess they forgot about it so the the
car was infested with German cockroaches
so there was that but I've had it for
years and years and years and I've
hardly ever had a single problem with it
it's like like I said it looks like ass
and it's just kind of like it's one of
the ugliest cars you'll ever see but it
still runs so I'm not complaining it's
got some little problems but nothing
that's know now that I say that it's
probably going to break down like
tomorrow but you know what I mean um all
right so where was I so we were talking
about Jim Corbett yeah so he end up okay
so all of the man eaing animals that he
killed they um
estimate that of all the man eating
animals that he killed those animals may
have killed as many as
1,200 people so he has a high cuz you
know like he not only killed the panar
leopard he also killed the you know
Maneater that I'm going to talk about
next which is the Champa tiger he also
killed other maneaters too like the T um
the talides Maneater Mohan Maneater F
Mane eater uh massar Maneater and the
chaar tiger so those were either tigers
or leopards but so he killed like a lot
of big cats that killed a bunch of
people so he's kind of like I said kind
of a badass and he was sort of the one I
don't know if he was the first person
to put this Theory forward but he did
find that a lot of the maneaters that he
killed had some kind of injury like
they'd either been shot or their teeth
were [__] up or something like that so
that's he kind of came up with this
theory that it's like oh well they're
injured and they can't hunt the regular
prey anymore and that's why they're
going after people
maybe like I don't I don't know if he
was the first person to come up with
that but that was just something that he
noticed um another funny little fact
that I discovered when I was looking at
Jim Corbett was that he didn't take
anybody with him he liked to go hunting
by himself uh and he always went on foot
but the only um other creature he took
with him with his little dog Robin him
and Robin would go out
hunting then he would just go out and
like kill [__] leopards and [__] like
that just all on his own which is like I
said super badass so here's another big
cat this was another one that Jim
Corbett killed this was the champawat
tiger um now this is a rare case of a
female animal being a maner um just as
in human beings most of the maneaters
are male animals but uh this one was a
female now this tiger is thought to have
killed more people than any other um
well tigers in general are known to have
thought to have killed more people than
any other big cat um and
possibly responsible for more human
deaths than any other wild
mammal um and mammal is the distinction
because there are other like crocodiles
and stuff like that that have killed
more people but as far as mammals go
Tiger's top of the top of the chain
there interestingly tigers usually also
attacked attack during the day day uh
leopards and Lions usually attack at
night like I said when people are
sleeping but Tigers they do not give a
[__] they will just come in in the
daytime and [__] your [__] up I think
the O overall the number one killer
though when it comes to mammals I think
or
animals it was either the hippo or the
damn water
buffalo from what I remember um it's
either hippo or crocodile okay um I
thought that water buffalo also maybe
African water buffalo I thought was even
more deadly there's more of them
though you know what I mean there's more
of those so it might be a statistical
thing yeah it's like there's a [__] ton
of [__] black bears more people are
killed by black bears than any other
bear not black bears yeah black bear
really black bear kills the most people
but there's more of them but there's so
many of them that's a small percentage
of the black bears doing it and they're
around human habitation yeah Kodiak and
[__] polar bear and [__] Grizz
would kill a lot more po but they're not
around human oh and polar bears
absolutely will hunt humans for food but
the thing about it is that there's not
enough humans around for them to like
make it statistical right somebody in
there was talking about how bad the
Grizzlies were Grizzly's nothing
compared to a polar bear just that
they're not around people but a polar
bear will [__] eat you if they see
they're they're always hungry and
they're in a place where they got to eat
everything they see because there's not
much there yeah CU there's not much
around there's not much there and evid
polar bear will track you for
weeks yeah they're scent that's it track
you for [__] weeks cuz they're like o
food they're hungry cuz they they'll
walk a long way to get something to eat
which you know you can understand that
they're living on a [__] desolate
Frozen ice cap man yeah I mean don't go
SAE and across the [__] Arctic or
anything like that thinking you're all
cool and [__] because you get eat your
assy by polar polar bear's biggest out
big biggest bear of them all I think I
think it's bigger than a Kodiak uh I
believe they are I would have to look
that up but yeah polar bears generally
are very very large yeah very
large um's wait hold on let me see
uh DVD Dragon says grizzly bears are the
worst they will eat you ass first and
not even buy you a drink that's guy was
talking about bear worse polar bear is
worse they just just not around them it
all yeah it all depends statistically on
how you know how many people are they
around yeah cuz obviously like a lot of
bears polar bear would if there were
people all over the place yeah they'd
probably snack them all the time yeah
but the top bear top bear is the black
bear that's because there's so many of
them and they live in places hum live
right like I said we used to see black
bears all the time they were sitting in
our [__] driveway you know what I
mean and they're they're mostly dosel
but because they're around people when
you have the odd black bear who decides
it's going to eat people it's it does I
but I think overall in numbers they're
the number one bear human killer bear
black bear like I said the chances of
you seeing a black bear that will kill
you is near
zero I mean normally if you leave them
alone like I said particularly in
Sanford I don't think I've seen any
around
here not well maybe but in Sanford we
used to see them all the time yeah and
no one's just walking around in the
neighborhood yeah no one's been eating
we saw when in the middle of the day
walk just strolling into someone's
garage came back from the open came back
from the club and had one sitting in our
parking lot in our driveway in our
driveway yeah yeah he was sitting on
just sitting there by the garage yeah
his back up against the garage in goes
oh [__] and he rolls over just off nice
and Calon he was bigger than a big man
yeah he was he was big that's very funny
he's probably 400 lbs I saw a family of
them running across the street in the
middle of the day too well it was like I
think it was like five or six o'clock
yeah when I was coming home from work
yeah and I saw a bunch of him just
walking through somebody he was big
enough easily to kill and eat a man but
he didn't he just walked away they're
eating the garbage cans he was chill
yeah they don't really they're not
desperate for food they're like hey
there's garbage cans with yummy food
they're all full they're licking all
your pizza boxes and all that kind of
[__] you know what I
mean so uh so yeah so late 19th early
20th century uh there's this region
called champawat which is nepes uh near
the
Himalayas and they were uh prayed upon
by one of the worst maneaters of all
time the champawat tiger or Tigress as
they call her now she would like ambush
people that were coming through the
jungle or everything like that and this
was like a lot of people she I believe
she killed I want to say it's
436 people 436
people um now again just like Jim
Corvett was saying this tiger had been
shot by a hunter but had gotten away so
she was um injured I believe she had
been shot in the face and two of her
fangs were
broken so they surmised that because her
teeth were [__] up and she couldn't
hunt her regular prey she decided she
was going to start praying on
people um now they did send Hunters out
after her um you know once the body
count got up in the
200s but um they couldn't really find
her apparently she was like pretty smart
and knew how to hide and [__] like
that um the nepes government eventually
sent the national Army after the tiger
uh because it was getting a little out
of hand you know what I mean um but they
didn't get her either now because of all
the activity uh she did actually move
her territory to India uh to the
champawat region and then she continued
eating people over there now they said
that every single person that she ate
she started getting more uh fearless and
eventually would just start attacking
people like she didn't really give a
[__] anymore she was just like attacking
people in broad daylight and kind of run
around Villages and [__] like that and
just attacking people they were walking
around yeah oh sod's there what's up sod
how you been bro yeah there you go
yeah so yeah so at some point she had
eaten so many people that um they're
like okay we need to bring in a
professional for this and the
professional they brought in was the
aforementioned Jim Corbett um so he came
in his story was because he wrote a
couple of books about his exploits and
he talked about the hunting this
tiger and he um followed a trail I guess
the tiger had taken a teenage girl from
a village and had left a trail of like
blood and limb
um you know so Jim's like well now's my
chance and he follows the trail of blood
and limbs like into the wherever the
tiger was and went after
her so he actually did end up shooting
the Tiger in
1911 now because the uh the towns people
there were like so happy that he had
done it they made him like a holy man
you know what I mean which I guess you
know cuz she killed like hundreds of
people at this point uh yeah 436 humans
yeah I was right about that um and those
were only the ones that they knew about
it's entirely possible that she might
have killed a lot more people than that
and they just didn't know like they
didn't report it or the people got eaten
or dragged away or missing and nobody
reported it or whatever so at least 436
that's crazy uh so I think that this
tiger is
still the worst single Maneater in
history because remember I said that the
nambe Lions
killed between 1500 and 2,000 people but
that was a bunch of lions that was a
whole pride of lions this is one single
tiger one single tiger they killed at
least
436 people um and one uh one article
that I
read said that she killed more people
than even the worst human serial killers
other than you know genocide
obviously um and it says this is funny
the only serial killer alleged serial
killer
um that had a similar body count was
Elizabeth bathy who was known as The
Tigress of someplace that I can't
pronounce but you know what I mean so I
thought that was kind of funny so we did
a show about Elizabeth B and it's like
I'm not entirely sure how much of that
[__] is true and how much of that was
exaggeration you know they have they
supposedly the authorities have her
diary but won't anybody see it yeah so I
don't read Parts they just said you know
I'm not saying she wasn't a horrible
person I mean she maybe she was but I'm
just saying I don't know if some it was
like
exaggerated the further you go back in
time the more famous and notable those
people are the more you have to wonder
how much of you how much of their
stories are legends yeah I think I mean
there was even people that thought that
maybe even Julius Caesar was a was a
[__] mythical person
but historians that come back and says
well we know the secession of the
Emperors and the names of the Emperors
and and you know what I mean and we know
the the names of the prors and in the
orders they were so who was
imperator you know what I mean in that
period it had to be somebody so it must
have been this guy Julius Caesar that
they're talking about even though he
wasn't he wasn't emperator he was
dictator which is
different his
adopted son Augustus was the first
emperor but I mean there's a lot of lot
of historical characters I don't I'm not
even sure they actually
existed there's a chance [__]
Socrates and plate were were never
existed because there's a lot of fake
Socrates out there books and [__] I mean
the thing about it is is that just
because there's fake [__] that was
attributed them later on doesn't mean
that they didn't necessarily exist but
it does kind of like make you question I
remember I remember uh one author
commented that a lot of the people of
antiquity and a lot of the famous
figures in Antiquity we believe that
they're historical because the Ancients
believed that they were historical so a
lot of times we're getting their stories
headed down it's not the first additions
you know but we don't know the Ancients
believed that they existed but the
Ancients believed in all kinds of [__]
that didn't exist the anxious believed
in in dog dog-headed people sometimes
the weird [__]
like there was no Marco Polo it's a
fictional
character I'm really suspect about Jon
Jon ofar there's too much about that
story that sounds like myth sounds like
Legend but like I said it could be that
it was a real person but then like a lot
of mythical stuff got attribute to them
to later on so it could be that it
doesn't necessarily mean that person
didn't exist ever but it was just that
they had all these stories like attached
to them later right so there's that
possibility also because people do like
to embellish [__] like later on
especially if somebody's like super
famous or super legendary or whatever so
let's talk about I think somebody
brought this up earlier and I thought
that we had already done a show about
this the Beast of Javad
Dan um I thought we talked about it when
we talked about when we did our vampire
and werewolf show but maybe not because
I did a search for it on our Channel and
I couldn't find
anything but I don't know I kind of feel
like this might need its own show
because cuz it's like so tied in with
werewolf Legends I'm going to say though
that I think the Beast of jodan which
was a real thing like it was a real
series of attacks that
happened um I don't know I think maybe
the
overriding theory is that it was a wolf
or a pair of wolves that were unusually
large but after seeing a few things
about it and I probably and I think you
probably agree with me on this I think
it was probably a hyena yeah the way
they describe it it's sounds like a
hyena to me yeah they're mistaking a
hyena for a wolf they say it's a wolf
it's like a wolf but it's not a wolf
what they're they said I think they said
it had stripes on it did it the way and
well they said it had like a man type of
thing like the way they described it
like sounds like a h tail with a ball on
the end of it it sounds like a hyena me
probably a hyena even though hyena
doesn't have a tail with a ball on the
end of it it's just no but well like I
said I don't think it was a [__]
werewolf either no but I mean it was it
was a thing it killed a bunch of people
they killed it people saw it and said
yeah that's not a wolf yeah kind of like
a wolf but not really they showed it to
the king of France it was rotten he says
get that thing out of here which is
awesome it was probably a hyena I'm kind
of leaning toward that theory I kind of
think a nobleman had bought a hyena
because noblemen back then had private
zoos they collected animals I think he
bought a hyena and hyena got out and
started eating people he didn't want to
fess up to it yeah he's he I didn't do
it not me I don't even know what that is
talking about African hyena yeah so the
attacks happened there were a lot of
them uh between uh in Javan which is in
France between 1764 and
1767 um the thing about it is that even
though a lot of people perceived it to
be a wolf or a werewolf even um people
of the time there were wolves in the
area back then so they would have
recognized it as a wolf if it was one um
the way it was described they said it
kind of looked like a wolf but it was
was bigger and it was kind of redish
like its fur was kind of reddish and
then it smelled really bad which like I
said again that sounds like a hyena to
me probably a big old female hyena yeah
so the first victim was a little girl uh
which it killed in June of
1764 and apparently the animal some
Reports say there were maybe two of them
they're not really sure because I think
some of the uh eyewitness reports said
that there were actually two of the
animals which is entirely possible sure
um the weird thing they said that the
the animals seem to attack humans and
not other prey animals like it didn't
attack domestic or cows or anything like
that it would just go after humans
specifically um in total as far as they
know 210 humans were attacked uh of
those 113 victims died 98 of those were
eaten partially eaten
um because the attacks during this with
three-year period were so frequent uh
again like people at the time would
think they thought it was like some
punishment from God or some [__] like
that like I said um I kind of feel like
the Beast of Javan gets brought up a lot
when people talk about werewolf Legends
because a lot of people thought it was a
werewolf um and you know from some of
the descriptions it does kind of sound
like a wolf but there were some European
wolves around at that time and people
would have recognized it and some people
said yeah it kind of looked like a wolf
but not you know what I mean and some of
the drawings of it I don't know I I kind
of feel like I think it's a hyena to be
honest um and I think it was probably
escape from aou or something or you know
some nobleman had some private
collection of exotic animals or
something and it got out and like Tom
said he didn't want to fess up to it so
he's just like I I don't have any idea
what you're talking about um because
there was a case fairly recently in uh
Malawi where a man-eating hyena attacked
a bunch of people um so they do do that
they're not really known for doing that
but you know animals can go Rogue and do
that kind of [__] uh so hyenas do have
big ass teeth they do smell uh pretty
funky and they are generally sometimes
bigger than an average wolf would be and
you know people in France at this time
period wouldn't necessarily recognize a
hyena because they weren't native to the
area and they are a little bit weird
looking you know what I mean they had
that kind of spine M thing like on their
back and [__] like that so it's like if
you saw that running around and it was
bigger than a wolf and it's just kind of
like and it smelled funny and [__] like
that you're like what the [__] is that
CU they wouldn't have seen it you know
what I mean yeah I kind of suspect
that's probably what it was Europeans
didn't know what animals
were they didn't know foreign animals
they know an animal when it was an
animal they get they get real confused
and and about what was related to what
if they saw that uh something like a
like a hyena they'd probably would only
be able to equate that with with a
wolf and [__] like
this has gone on for a long time and it
went way into the modern era people
don't realize in the early 1900s the New
York Zoo had pygmies in it pygmy humans
in the zoo yeah yeah like they were
animal insane yeah that's a person
yeah you went to zoo to go see some
African pygmy people in there
we don't know what and it was evidently
they were in there for a while before
they said look you got to let those go
man yes it's like um those are human
beings can we not thanks
yeah man people are imagine that huh
were dumb as [__] back then look it up
people if you don't believe me no it's
true it's true New York Zoo had pygmies
in it yeah and it wasn't really that
long ago I mean to be honest yeah I
think that was even I think they had him
in there to almost almost
1920s it might well I don't know if it
was quite that recent but it it wouldn't
shock me if it was that recent I'd have
to look it
up but and they weren't being
mean-spirited they just they didn't know
any better they didn't know any better
they weren't sure they but the thing
about it is that can't be a person being
mean spirited and just being stupid as
[__] yeah if the end result is the same
it doesn't really matter does it because
the end result is the same they didn't
think about it they you're putting a
person in a cage in a cage and having
them and like the people in the cage
going what the [__] is going on why are
we in here what is happening right now
although they may have seen other people
that weren't pygmies is because
evidently even even on the continent of
Africa freak out I even think to this
day where the pygmies live still think
that the surrounding African people hunt
and kill them and eat them last I heard
and that was during theed up they don't
see them as
people a't that weird yeah that is
pretty weird yeah yeah that is pretty
weird so yeah Danny rling said you
definitely did do a show about the Beast
of Javad I thought we had yeah I thought
like I said I thought we talked about on
the werewolf show it we didn't do a
whole show on it we mentioned it in
another show I think we mentioned it on
the werewolf show maybe um but it was
actually killed eventually uh by a fella
who was a hunter named Jean chastel in
1767 um now even though the legend says
he used a silver bullet and that's
obviously that was probably like a later
interpolation I would imagine
um but it was eventually killed so
people did see
it but they didn't know what it was so I
I I lean toward the hyena Theory you
know what I mean thank you very much
Bryce that is very very nice thank you
what you say this might be controversial
to say but I don't feel the same outrage
when an animal hurts someone instead of
when a human does it I kind of don't
either to be honest with you well it's
just animal just do it a SN yeah it
doesn't know like to me it's tragic but
I'm not ready to join a m with torches
and pitchforks yeah it's definitely not
the same like when a bear eats a person
like Grizzly Man or whatever like that
sucks and that's horrible and I don't
want to listen to the audio and stuff
that's fa game though but yeah on the
other hand that dude was hanging out
with grizzly bears which you don't have
to do in their territory I'm not saying
he was asking for it I'm just saying
that
it's it was maybe an inevitable outcome
he was playing he didn't deserve that
I'm not saying that but I'm just saying
that the bear didn't know any better
bear just saw him as a foreign creature
that had right you know yeah and he
wasn't about to other other Bears could
you know have friendship with the guy
but not that particular bear people they
got people like that some people you
can't [__] with you know other ones you
can he ran into the wrong bear and he
knew that that bear would eat him he
says if I ever get eaten by a bear it's
that's another kind of thing he saw that
bear again and he goes oh [__] and it
ate him I mean that's the thing it's
just like I kind of feel like I said he
didn't deserve that happening to him but
he knew the risk though he knew yeah
that that might happen and he called it
he he he knew what bear would eat him I
mean you're hanging out with wild
animals you better be okay with the
outcome that you might get eaten by by
said wild animal remember I remember
watching his movie he was okay with that
he said he was willing he was willing to
give his life for the Bears well okay
and that's what happened that's what
happened and his girlfriend I think was
like that too cuz she she knew the risk
too but he was telling her to run she
didn't run if she had she run she'd have
lived yeah yeah bear would have chased
her I don't think but like I said I
can't really blame her because like I
said if you were getting eaten by a bear
I'm not going to [__] leave you there
you
better then you'd be you'd be next on
the list I know but I don't think I'd be
able to I just wouldn't be able to you
have to I'm not that kind of person
survival I know I'm just not that kind
of person and maybe she wasn't either
you know what I mean so I get it you're
going to die you're going to get that
that Darwin Award supp to run he was
telling her you run she wouldn't run I
know I get it yeah but you knew that
there was no way but see yeah but the
thing he couldn't be saved right so you
take the the second best option is to
use my death is a distraction so you can
get away like I'll get away so only one
dies instead of two and that he called
it right she called it wrong she should
have
run I know but like I said I understand
why she didn't though I understand why
he told her to run well I understand
that too yeah but I understand why she
didn't she went down with it but the
thing about it is that but I get what
you're saying because you know an animal
is just doing what it does it's got to
eat yeah prot it doesn't have like a
moral framework to be like oh this is a
person I shouldn't do this or anything
like that but a person absolutely knows
better well the thing is is that you're
putting Morality In it from the Bear's
point of view that is the cor correct
moral this thing doesn't belong here and
I'm hungry this is not a bear well
that's what I mean it's like it doesn't
have the same moral framework as a human
has that's what I'm saying but like I
said a human absolutely knows better um
so you go and [__] with an animal you go
and do something to an animal that was
just mining its own business yeah then
to me like you [__] with like we were
saying about that [__] douchebag
before what was his name Luke some Luca
I can't remember his last what he do the
the one that put the kittens in the bag
and then like later killed oh that dud
yeah I like that dude um even if he
hadn't killed a person later on like
just from doing the thing with the
kittens I'm like yeah we need to take
that person out of the je pool
immediately he's putting kittens in
Ziploc bags and watching him suffocate
in there and he was being all pretty boy
and [__] about it like that [__] was
sexy I'll [__] kill you for doing
[__] like that that's what I mean
[__] danger and I think most people
would probably they'd be like y yeah y
that's what happens and then he was
meeting up with people to feed kittens
to [__] anacondas and boa
constrictors
man they got rats for that yeah you not
cool either but I mean snakes got to eat
too you know yeah you you can go buy rat
food and it's it's yeah you can buy
snake food and it's rats or
mice and they give them live that's just
how it is in nature yeah um but there
there's no reason to give them cat
kittens yeah kittens aren't M or kittens
aren't rats yeah you know it's not the
same niche in
nature yeah that's what I mean yeah like
I said I wouldn't I like snakes but I
wouldn't have a snake just cuz that cuz
I really don't like the thought of
having to feed them or cuz I like rats
too you know what I mean but I know they
got to eat so but I has to live I know
but I don't want to do it nature is
about things trying to kill each other
yeah including the plants the plants are
trying to kill each other by stealing
nutrients and sunlight everything tries
to kill everything
else in its own Arena EX at me I'm not
killing anybody well you eat things
everything you eat everything you eat
was alive oh I know I didn't kill it
though you got the creatures living in
you right now that your body's trying to
kill or your there's only three
relationships
predation
parasitism and symbiosis that's
it or I guess you said there's also no
relationship there's only three things
you can do so that's four things yeah
what's that that's four things yeah yeah
or three or four yeah if there's no
relationship then it's
four yeah Bryce said uh yeah I'm with
you on that I'm outraged when a human
hurts an animal even if they don't hurt
humans yeah it's just I'm just it's a
precursor to hurting humans yeah anybody
that can do that to a person or do that
to an animal would do that to a person I
feel
like and especially if it's a little
helpless animal I only approve of
hurting people if it's goal directed or
if it serves a mission or if it em or if
it betters your your people and I
understand it then it's understandable
and it's between adults
usually but you're not gaining anything
from needless death you know I mean
that's you don't animals in nature
intend not to kill other animals for no
reason at all some will kill an animal
like Pooky will kill lizards to play
with them but eventually she she might
go or ba Beijing does it and eventually
she might go back to take a few bites
out of it but she doesn't really want to
eat it but I don't think she killed them
on purpose I think she's mostly playing
with them Pooky for sure does not kill
lizards on purpose she's not
mean-spirited she's just like oo a toy
trying to play with it it moves yeah and
like so when we could like you know
she's not trying to kill it she's just
trying to play with she's like like and
we're just like oh my God's like help me
yeah and they just bite they bite
automatically it's just part of holding
it you know yeah and I mean yeah I mean
they bite us like not like with just
when they're playing like soft you know
what I mean they're just kind of like
you know what I mean they just do
that but yeah so they don't realize so
like I said I never thought that Pooky
was like trying to kill the lizards she
was just playing with them the most
vicious things the most vicious animals
that I've seen that did did [__]
needlessly were great apes like
chimpanzees they'll kill other
chimpanzees from other groups for no
reason and they do it in gang because
they're closer to humans that's why yeah
they're kind of creative about yeah the
closer the closer you get to humans the
more you get that kind of shenanigans
yeah well humans are very
similar if you see how chimps
kill they'll be at a pack and they'll go
out and look for an outside male an
outsider male from another troop and
they'll surround him and he's trying to
get out and one of them will grab his
leg or the other one will grab the arm
and they'll start stretching him out
other on will go in and bite his dick
off and then they'll kill him that way
and then they just kind of lose interest
and walk off like wow that was weird and
then they do it again little war parties
well seral kill trying to drive out the
other I think they're just trying to
drive away the other groups yeah
probably um probably time for another
drink but uh after that we're going to
talk about getting out of the Big Cat
arena gonna talk about the very famous
New Jersey shark or sharks might have
been two this was the series of shark
attacks that inspired Peter benchley to
write Jaws which in turn inspired Steven
Spielberg to make the movie Jaws in
1975 um I just you know what Jaws just
going to say that this is one of the
very few situations where the movie is
much better than the book gonna say it I
read Peter benchley's Jaws it's good
but man there's a lot of unnecessary
subplots in there and the characters are
not as sympathetic as they are in the
movie I'm going to say that right
now so um so so yeah there's all kind of
like weird [__] in the book that really
doesn't need to be in there the movie is
much much better but if you didn't know
uh Peter benchley's Jaws was actually
based on a real series of events that
happened way the [__] back in 1916 off
the coast of New Jersey now this was
1916 and this might be crazy to think
about now but back
then I don't think people really
realized
um it this seems we but I don't I don't
think they realized that like sharks
were dangerous maybe or they didn't
really think about it one way or the
other which like I said seems kind of
strange um now these sharks I okay
there's controversy over whether these
attacks were all carried out by one
shark or maybe it was two they're not
entirely
sure but like I said it was uh along the
coast of New Jersey
1916 so the first person that was
attacked he was this guy he was kind of
of a young guy um named Charles
vanan and he was swimming with his dog
in Fairly shallow water off the coast of
New
Jersey and he was attacked by a
shark now his uh members of his family
and uh friends of his and stuff like
that were on the shore and so they saw
like some of the attack which must have
been horrible I can't
imagine so they saw something was
happening and they kind of a lifeguard
ran out there to help him now what
apparently happened was the shark like
[__] him up right and then like the
Lifeguard came out and was like dragging
him to the shore and the shark followed
the Lifeguard for a little while this
the Lifeguard wasn't
bitten but they but he actually managed
to get him to the
shore now what had happened was that
Charles's uh femoral arteries were um
severed
and one of his legs um the shark had
eaten like all the flesh off it so it
was basically just like muscle right so
he's on so they called an ambulance
obviously or whatever the 1916
equivalent was um but it didn't get
there quick enough he actually bled to
death by the time help arrived which
like I said that's kind of what if you
get your leg def fleshed uh that's going
to happen to you
five days after that that's yours oh
yeah that's not that's the two-handed
glass I can't even I I have to hold it
like this cuz my little tiny hand my
baby hand five days after that attack
there was another guy whose name was
Charles Bruder and he was attacked by
what they thought was the same shark in
a similar area and he was out uh kind of
swimming he wasn't too far out but you
know he's out there swimming like like
you
do um one witness on the shore who saw
the
attack told authorities this is messed
up he told authorities at first that he
thought a red boat had capsized but
actually it was just all the [__]
blood in the water is what it was uh the
shark had actually bitten off both of
the dude's
legs they did manage to get out there
and drag him back to the
shore um and you know he was all [__]
up and
Al uh briefly yeah lot blood loss yeah
you get both your legs bit off you're
not uh living too long after that sorry
um both femoral arteries severed yeah
yeah well like I said the first guy the
shark attacked it bit his legs but it
stripped all the flesh off one of the
legs he lived though no he died he died
too he bled a death yeah after they
dragg him to the shore [__] same kind of
thing uh man I would never want to be
eaten by a shark because that's what I
mean you alive oh that'd be the worst
RoR sharp [__] it's awful it's
awful like being bitten by a mass of
razor blades I have nightmares about
just being in this kind of black
nothingness and then just seeing like a
shark F like an eye like wait I have
nightmares like that GH or like seeing
one coming out of the darkness like a
big old pair of [__] metal Snips
filled with [__] razor blade teeth
just go right through you in a single
bite go right through you go right
through your bones here's the thing they
tell you nowadays it's like oh well most
sharks they don't mean to attack a
person they just kind of see you there
and it's like oh wonder if I could eat
that and then they bite you but it's
just kind of like oh well they don't
really want to eat you they just want to
check and see if you're food but it's
like at that point you're already dead
because they've already bit your [__]
leg off you know what I mean so it's
like I'm sorry that doesn't make me feel
any better from the bottom looking up
you might you look like a seal or swi
that's what they always say especially
if you're on a surfboard cuz a lot of
surfers do get attacked but you know
what I mean they're not sure and they
evident evidently they're around their
mouth there's a bunch of
sensory cells
nerves and if anything touches them they
Instinct reflexively just bite and pull
in yeah they like they're not making
they're not making a decision to bite
it's like a [__] fuse on the end of a
[__] bomb if it touches anything it
just
bites which is you know like I said
event they spit it out if it's a human
they go usually cuz it's all bones and
they're like a that's no good then
they'll [__] swim off and then you're
[__] Bing part of you [__] you
know you're half a man and you're
bobbing up and down in a sea dying right
that's what I mean they're only taking
like a little experimental bite but that
experimental bite has bitten you in half
so you're not going to survive that
obviously yeah they don't expect to have
a bite full of bunch of bone they want
it to be something like bunch of blubber
and flesh and [__] like they bit the
side of a whale or bit a [__] porpus
or a dolphin in half there's a lot of
meat there it's like a chicken leg or
something too many bones I don't like it
but like I said they've still killed you
so
but well and the thing about it like I
said I grew up in Daytona Beach and I
used to go to the beach a lot as a kid
uh not necessarily my decision I'm not a
beach person but my mom loved the beach
so she used to take us all the time when
I was little and um you know I would
never go out too deep because
sharks um and Barracuda also I wasn't a
big fan of those oh and um also sting or
like jelly jellyfish we always had like
a lot of jellyfish that would sting you
and like we were there at the beach lots
of times when people got stung yeah
they're not biting you to see what you
taste like they don't have a sense of
taste they don't have a sense of smell
and they know what the bite is supposed
to feel like if it's got a lot of bones
in it they that's not what they're
looking for but once once there's blood
in the water they love that smell
they'll start going into Fe like we're
going to eat all okay all right they can
the closest thing they have to taste is
that smell they can smell blood
evidently miles away MH yeah yeah it
doesn't have to be much blood either no
that's why don't go in the water like
when you're on your period or if you
have a cut that's bleeding or anything
like that seriously but I have had I
haven't had that many en I've had like a
small shark like kind of swim against my
leg which I was just like nope I'm out
of the ocean for the day bye and I was
only in like Knee Deep Water and I was
just kind of like yeah no um and when I
was in my Marine Biology class in high
school they were sh showing us a photo
that someone had taken from a helicopter
of Daytona Beach which is where I'm from
and here's like all the little people
swimming in the water going we we're
like swimming at Daytona Beach and then
out here it was just like
sharks like a whole bunch of them you
could see their Silhouettes in the water
and I was just like well I'm never going
to the ocean ever again and even a small
shark could take a bite out of you is
the size of an apple and and they
weren't like great whites or nothing
they're they're probably Sand Sharks is
probably what they were but they still
sand sharks have these [__] up kind of
teeth that stick out like that like all
crooked but um yeah especially after I
saw that picture I'm just like well I
wasn't like super jazzed about going to
the ocean before that anyway but after I
saw that picture I'm just like yeah no
thanks cuz it's just like what like 10
ft there's all these people swimming
right there in this shallow water and
there was just like just sharks
everywhere some of them might have been
Dolphins I don't know but
still that's that's pretty messed up
Bryce says uh yeah animals killing each
other doesn't bother me either my cat
has killed so many birds she's still a
good girl to me yeah Pooky kills lizards
and they're just doing what they do
that's how that's just how they they
can't help it look at her little face
Beijing killed a squirrel one time tore
its head off yeah I think Beijing did
that and she killed some moles or
something once yeah a mole and Gophers
yeah she kills those yeah like I said
Pooky doesn't go outside much anymore so
she doesn't really kill kill anything
but she does kill lizards if they get in
the house pie got chased by a dog after
that she doesn't want anything to do
with outside which I'm kind of happy
about cuz I don't really like her going
outside especially around here because
it's kind of all
open you know yeah and I don't really
like her going outside like in this open
area but yeah so this guy got his legs
bit off they dragged him up to the shore
but obviously it was he was dead by the
time they got him up there it was too
late to save him now people ad said that
they saw some sharks in the area prior
to these two attacks um but because this
was 1916 and they didn't really have a
good handle on sharks in general
evidently um they thought that it maybe
wasn't the sharks that were doing it
they thought it was a killer
whale
which okay but I mean killer
whales they have been known to attack
people but I think that's a lot rarer
than shark attacks and shark attacks are
actually pretty rare now there was
another set of attacks that took place
in the same area but not in the ocean it
was actually a creek near this town
called um I think he pronounce it mwan I
think it's
mwan now some people several witnesses
reported they saw a shark swimming in
the creek but nobody really paid
attention to
them um until July 12th there was an
11-year-old boy who was swimming in the
creek and he was attacked by the shark
and drags
underwater now a bunch of the other
people saw it happen and they rushed
down there and a dude named Stanley
fiser jumped into the water to try to
save the kid and that dude got attacked
by the shark and killed
also now the last victim was another kid
and this was um only about half an hour
later like after the first attack in the
creek um now this kid actually survived
he was wounded but he
lived now a couple days after the mwan
creek
attacks they caught a female great white
shark uh near mwan
Creek Now The Story Goes that they cut
her stomach open and that they found
human remains in
there now so a lot of people think oh
well this was the shark that did all the
attacks obviously because there were
some human remains in there but not
everybody is sure that the same shark
was responsible for both attacks they
think maybe the great white did the
stuff in the
ocean and that maybe the attacks in the
creek were a bull shark because but see
the thing about it was that this was
kind of the whole um incident that
spurred the whole oh my God great white
sharks are the worst now I'm not saying
they're not because of all the you know
shark attacks are relatively rare but of
all the shark attacks yeah great whites
are in the top three I think of like you
know sharks that attack
humans but I think this was the kind of
thing like oh my God great white sharks
are the worst but actually bull sharks I
think are responsible for more attacks
on humans or and are generally more
aggressive and the thing about bull
sharks is that they can actually surv
dve in fresh water which is why a lot of
people thought that maybe that that it
was a bull shark like responsible for
the one there also a lot more of them
and they're in areas where people are
yeah great whites not so much that's why
just like with the black bear yeah is
statistics so so yeah so I kind of feel
and and I think people um underplay the
uh tiger shark as well yeah tiger shark
will also attack and a tiger shark will
eat anything they don't care what it's
made of they found bicycles and car
parts and all kind of [__] in if I
remember correctly the tiger shark also
can be found sometimes in freshwater
lakes where you would well bull shark
too yeah you yeah bull shark also I
think the tiger also I think they both
you could be in a [__] Lake if it's
connected to fresh water yeah and get
eaten by these who yeah it's happened
it's happened because they'll get into
fresh water they can live quite a while
in it well as far as I know like I said
I grew up in Daytona Beach and I don't
know if you know but in Daytona Beach
where it's right on the Atlantic Ocean
but it's kind of on there's like a strip
of land um you know where A1A is it's
only like a mile across or something and
then there's a river the Halifax River
and that River at some point hooks up
with the Atlantic Ocean so every now and
then um you'd be driving down the street
next to the Halifax and you would see
dolphins or something like a shark fin
or something like that like in the river
because it's attached you know you know
what I mean yeah and they'll go up in
there for some reason I'm not sure if
the biologists really know know what's
what the deal is but evidently some of
these sharks get sick of salt water
maybe I guess maybe the hunting isn't
good or they're having a hard time he's
like I'm just going to go check out
what's going on they swim up a
freshwater [__] River to try to get
into a lake and evidently they can be in
there for months they're not supposed to
be in fresh water but they're tough they
can survive it then they go back out to
the Sea weird can you imagine imagine
being in a lake thinking you're [__]
all safe and [__] and get a [__] bite
taken out of You by a [__] bull shark
or just be killed by a [__] 12 foot
10 foot Bull Shark well it it happened
in this situation happened yeah in a
creek yeah so you never suspected you
I'd never even be thinking about it well
like I said I'm from Florida so even
when I'm in a lake I'm just thinking I'm
going to be eaten by something with an
alligator or a shark or a catfish who
[__] knows I don't even know what's
down there and I don't want to know but
yeah so this shark uh they did catch the
great white and it did have human parts
in it so they know that that was
responsible for at least some of the
attacks but like I said they don't know
if there was another shark like perhaps
a bull shark that was attack uh
responsible for the attacks in the creek
and they as far as I know they never did
catch that one this was a very very
famous um series of shark attacks and it
almost appeared as though the shark was
targeting people specifically which I
think was the reason that it was such a
big story um and you know as I mentioned
earlier it did eventually end up
inspiring Peter benchley to write Jaws
later on uh which you know in turn
inspired the very famous movie um the
movie was also very responsible for
making people kill great white sharks
with wild abandon which you know
probably not great for the ecosystem
because as scary as shark attacks are
and I'm scared of sharks too but y can't
just I mean shark attacks are
statistically very very very rare I
think the reason that the reason that
they're so fascinating is because when
they happen they're like super horrific
and you can imagine what it would be
like like I said it's horrible to think
like anybody to think about eating being
eaten by a shark that's a horrible
fate so obviously that's going to stick
in people's minds like when it happens
but statistically it's very very very
rare the that that that would happen
that's not going to make me go in the
ocean though um I'm still not going in
there [__] that because I don't even
want to take I don't even want to take
the minuscule chance that I could get
eaten by one of those in the ocean huh
yeah I've swam in the ocean lots of
times but every single time I kept
thinking it's like what the [__] am I
doing in here man this is like not this
is this is shark house this is not my
house I mean when I was in I used to
swim in the ocean all the time but when
I was in when when I was working in siai
in the Army we used to go down to the
Gul of akaba right right outside charmil
Shake it's a it's a resort and we
snorkel off right off the reef it was
wild man there's all kinds of stuff in
there
octopus I had a damn sergeant major fish
and all little fish following around I
had some kind of I think a fish called a
sheep head oh yeah yeah looks like a
sheep's head yeah they're weird looking
that thing followed me around all
[__] day there I you know what I seen
videos of those fish they must be like
super curious or something because I've
seen other videos of like divers with
those fish like following them around
like hey what you doing yeah trying to
see what trying to see if I'm going to
stir up food that's probably what
they're doing I didn't though I guess he
was
disappointed looks like a head of a damn
sheep yeah they're weird looking weird
looking thing yeah they're weird looking
floating
around but yeah I
can't that's the thing like I said I
grew up right on the coast
so I used to go to the beach all the
time when I was a kid I didn't go out
super deep like I said because it's the
ocean and sharks live there and I'm just
like no thanks that's they can live
there I'll I'll be over here on the land
thank you very much but I did used to
swim around in there and I did have
sharks swim past my leg um we did
have
jellyfish uh you would see Barracuda
sometimes you would see um stingrays
sometimes small ones sh like that cuz
like I said I out super deep I said
something uh yeah they have sharks there
in Egypt a shark killed a guy in 2022
there my friend sod said that yeah most
of the time when I was there I was
worried about this
damn snail it was poisonous it lived
inside a shell and it it would Buri
itself in the in the sand and if you
stepped on it it would shoot a poison oh
yeah needle in you that's kind of like a
what is that fish called tremendously
painful Like a Stone Fish there's a
Stone Fish there's a fish that looks
like a rock yeah and it's super
poisonous too like if you step on it
like it has poisonous this is this isn't
a fish though no I know but I'm just
saying there's that similar it's a snail
and it's inside of a shell a round shell
like the size of a hand grenade I forgot
what it was
called uh luckily we didn't see
any I was more worried about that it's
like stepping on a land mine or
something well yeah they said it was
just tremendously painful and it can
kill you people died from it I forgot
what the [__] thing was called maybe
somebody in the comments
knows Bryce said my people believe that
if a shark eats someone that's fair
because it's her ocean yeah I get that
like I said I'm staying my ass out of
the ocean all right so the last thing I
was want to talk about let's go into the
Reptile Kingdom we're going to talk
about some snakes and alligators and
crocodiles so I wanted to talk about a
few
snakes that are not specific like
specific manator but you know in the
sense that there wasn't like an
individual one but this just kind of
fascinated me because people being eaten
alive by giant snakes is just that's
another kind of nightmare of mine um so
there aren't really obviously that many
Snake species that can swallow a person
like an adult human being usually it's
the shoulders uh that [__] up the the
whole issue there but uh there have been
some stories some of them have been
confirmed about big ass giant snakes
swallowing adults
now one of these happened in
2017 and this was in
Indonesia they found an adult person
inside of a 23 foot long python so it
had eaten a whole entire person and they
found the whole [__] body in there
which that blows my [__] mind and
that's another thing that would be
[__] up because a snake well they
usually eat you head first which I'm not
saying that would be good good either
because it would probably take a long
time for you to die right but still well
they Don't Eat You Alive they're
constrictors well that's true they wrap
around you and suffocate you so you're
already dead when they you're already
dead when they eat you
yeah and then there was another case in
2018 where there was like an older woman
she was in her 50s and she got eaten by
a reticulated python it was like in her
garden and it like popped out and ate
her yeah they just wrap around you and
when you exhale they tighten down and
you then you inhale they fight against
it and every time you exhale they just
[__] keep tightening down yeah
eventually you can't take a
breath I mean yeah constriction yep and
the thing about constrictors is that
even if they're relatively small like
we're talking 10 to 15 feet which is
still pretty [__] big for a snake but
I'm just saying it's small for a python
um they'll do they'll constrict you and
kill you even if they can't physically
swallow you because there are
some um reports of snakes that like
killed a person like a like a normaliz
adult person and then couldn't eat them
like they would just eat their head but
then they like had to kind of spit them
out or whatever because they weren't
they couldn't fit in there DVD Dragon
comes up with with cone snail was a
question mark oh yeah maybe I don't
think it was I don't think that's what
it was called wasn't quite a snail was a
type of
mullus and
uh it was in like a [__] shell kind of
looking thing it was smooth I think it
might have been called a tiger snail I
think maybe something like that we're
going have to look that up because
that's actually kind of interesting like
I said it just reminded me of Like a
Stone Fish which is kind of which like I
said is a fish but it looks like a rock
like it camouflages itself on the on the
seafloor yeah for some Reas and if you
step on it it has poison spines yeah
it's not this I know but I'm just saying
that's what I that's what it made me
think of but yeah so um let me get into
I have a couple of like I have an
alligator and a crocodile and then
that's the last stuff okay so you should
find this interesting because this is a
probably true and maybe somewhat
legendary tale from Florida and
Alabama and this is the legend of two
toad Tom that was the name of this
particular yeah
so this dude was a big ass
alligator And he supposedly was kind of
roaming through the swamps of Florida
and Alabama during the
1920s now the reason he was called
two-toed Tom was because one of his like
his little left hand he only had two
toes on it uh the story went that he
hadd been caught in an iron trap at some
point so the reason that they knew this
was the same Gator was because of his
Footprints because they were very
distinctive looking because he only had
two toes on his left
hand um uh according to witness reports
he was about 15t long and a lot of the
people uh who lived around in the area
thought that he was again a demon like
not a normal Gator because he apparently
ate a lot of people he started out
though eating livestock he would eat
mules and cows and other stuff he his
favorite human prey though was women who
would come to the water's edge to wash
their clothes like to do their laundry
and then he would just perfect Target
pull him yeah he would just pull him in
the water and eat him um stories about
Tutto Tom go back uh to 1922 I believe
the first written account was from
1934 which was from a book called Stars
fell on
Alabama and um in this book they
actually just called him Tut toe or red
eye uh they said he was 14t long and
that he ate livestock and both men and
women um also this book said that he
would rape the women before eating them
oh of course he would which of course
yeah okay someone's got a someone's got
a weird fetish where is this 1930s um
well it started out in Alabama but then
it moved to Florida yeah okay
yeah so this particular alligator uh so
it eats a bunch of people
and then there were a bunch of attempts
to kill it obviously um there was one
guy who had been in the military and he
was a sharpshooter and he like sat for
in a hunting blind like for a week like
wanted to kill it but he never did it
and there was another very famous
incident where there was a farmer whose
name was Pap Haynes which is the most
Alabama sounding farmer name ever
conceived um he decides he's going to
blow blow the swamp up where the
alligator is which that's sounds legit
so he gets all these syrup buckets like
15 of them and he fills them all with
dynamite and he puts them all in the
Swap and just blows the [__] swap to
Smither did he kill the alligator no he
killed like pretty much everything else
in the swamp though like all the other
fish and everything so good job Bryce
over New Zealand's wondering if uh
Europeans ever would actually read his
question now I wonder if any tribes or
ethnic groups have worshiped alligators
or crocodiles like my people worship
sharks that would be interesting to look
up yes there is
Europeans in the medieval period let me
didn't differentiate
between crocodiles and
dragons and Dragons Were a big part of
you know European
lore uh based on based on based on
[__] other [__] that I had read if
you were to show something like a
crocodile or an
alligator to to a European of that era
they just would have said that that was
a
dragon because I don't think that they
they don't they don't they don't ever
reference crocodiles and they didn't
have alligators I I don't think Europe
has any alligators in at all I think
that's I think that's a an American
thing now I wouldn't really call it
worship though it was just kind of
a dragons were always kind of uh in
medieval lore equated to the
devil um so they were
satanic they're always like the bad guys
Knights are always you know trying to go
out and kill a
dragon I don't know where they came up
with the idea but you've seen drawings
European drawings of they're two-legged
with
wings like a
serpent
in some
uh in some of the old kind of archaic
English type
languages a dragon is also called a worm
or
wyvern I don't know why the worms are
called worms they're calling those
dragons I guess Jenny would probably
know by what why is a worm called a worm
that means Dragon yeah why why are they
call those Dron R in
yeah in Dungeons and Dragons they also
called them wyverns which fing worm
because they probably to look up the
etymology of that because why are they
calling worms worms that's that's like
calling a worm a
dragon you know like an earthworm right
I don't understand why they did that in
English
but so wouldn't be any
worship of dragons and lizards but they
rever them re rever and fear them they
were like Satan you know yeah Satan was
also called a dragon in in the Book of
Revelations the Chinese worshiped them
though in a way they honored dragons as
something that was
good it's not quite the same creature
though really when you think about it
though in Chinese mythology they're yeah
dragons are very similar worldwide which
is really interesting but um Chinese
dragons tend to be good
yeah um whereas dragons in European
folklore are evil tend to be not always
but tend to be evil or Monsters yeah
which is kind of interesting I don't
know where they came up with this
idea this maybe they dug up a dinosaur
skull well see that's what I always
thought but there's like a whole you
need to get get into that maybe we
should do a show about that because
there's a whole people have written
whole papers on where the Dragon
mythology came from just because the
dragon mythology is so similar across
cultures which you don't really see like
with a lot of say yeah yeah they're like
the same things and it's like there's
cultural variations but there's not a
lot of cultural variations in Dragon
mythology and a lot of like folklores
and stuff think that's really
interesting so there's like a lot of um
papers and stuff about that if you were
to show a medieval Knight that aligator
Crossing that
Florida Florida [__] um Golf Course
that famous video of that [__] walking
he would have said that that was a
dragon that is a [__] dragon that a
horrifying video it was so big Egyptians
had crocodiles so it could be stories of
crocodiles made it as far as as Western
Europe they could have been yeah they
might have been talking about Egyptian
crocodiles yeah because Danny brings up
uh Egyptians worshiping a crocodile
deity yeah SOC yeah SOC yeah SOC well
well that's what I mean that's n
crocodiles so was a devil type creature
I think he which makes sense because
even today n crocodiles are one of the
most dangerous animals in the world like
as far as like killing humans goes yeah
so maybe the Chinese heard about a word
of mouth also during some ancient trade
routes yeah it could have been that
they've dug
up ancient Chinese or ancient uh Roman
ruins
and found Chinese coins in
it so there was some vague connection
with with China and Western Europe right
I think there was a lot more contact
than maybe we've been led to believe so
stories travel yeah you
know so maybe it's not as weird as it
seems that their stories about dragons
are so similar but there is like a whole
that's like a whole sub genre of folk
Flor like the dragon thing MH so I I
don't know maybe we should do a whole
show about that cuz that would probably
be really interesting dragons are an
interesting story yeah I would I
wouldn't mind getting into that the
whole world has dragons and the whole
world has
pyramids yeah that too yeah but but I
well pyramids are different like
depending on like different enough that
I don't know according to the Old
Testament Egypt had corn
also remember mhm
Joseph's dream he saw seven ears of corn
devoured by seven cows then the cows
didn't get any
better I didn't I don't know where this
corn thing came I didn't know that Egypt
had corn I thought they just had wheat
yeah I thought corn was a new world
thing yeah so where' that come from why
is it why why is it translated into
English from the Old Testament
corn well now see it must mean wheat
yeah it could be a mistranslation yeah
it could be that too right so Ben says
dragons built the pyramids we'll see now
there's a theory I haven't
seen there you go we're going to write a
book about that and make a million
dollars as Graham Hancock he'll probably
tell you all about he probably already
wrote a book dragons and [__] yeah
dragons and pyramids everybody's got
them I'm gonna write that down actually
I'm gonna write down dragons because
yeah I feel like I wanted to do a show
about that before but I never remembered
yeah there's a lot there that's what I
mean there's a whole and I love anything
to do with like comparative mythology I
love that kind of [__] it's just
fascinating to
me so um so yeah so this far where was I
okay so we were talking about this
alligator two toe
Tom so this farmer puts 15 buckets of
dynamite in the swamp I'm going to blow
this [__] alligator up that's typical
like Alabama kind of thinking and
Florida thinking too well they Dynamite
fish all the time back in that era it's
illegal well that's they made it illegal
because that is a s a very successful
way a [__] killing fish he dynamiting
them which is maybe not what you want to
Dynamite them [__] and they come come
dead ones all the fish pick them up out
of the swamp yeah now there's nothing
left everything's dead good job good job
but yeah so um so yeah he kills all the
fish in the swamp so the story goes but
um the alligator was smart enough to get
the [__] out of there I guess where he
wasn't around at the time so he didn't
kill the
alligator now again The Story Goes that
not long after he blew the swamp up the
farmer and his son who were also there
with him who was also there with him
they hear this horrible scream and they
hear all these splashing sounds like
from a pond like nearby so they go over
there to see what the commotion is and
they see the alligator's eyes like above
the water lying for a second and then
later they found uh the half eaten body
of The Farmer's Daughter so I guess the
alligator being like [__] you buddy I'm
going to eat your kid while you're
blowing my [__] up that's how that
happened so I don't know if that was a
true story if that was just like an
urban legend later on but um stories do
seem to indicate that this alligator was
a real
alligator and some people think that it
might be still
alive because this was just um you know
alligators live a long time and he has
been seen as recently as 2009 and some
people and he's been what what his thing
is is he'll like be around for a while
and then like he'll disappear for a few
years and nobody's like oh well he must
be dead and then he'll show back up
again you know what I mean so he has
been seen like fairly
recently so The Story Goes that after
the whole swamp exploding incident that
he moved from Alabama and decided he was
going to go to Florida so the story went
that he started Living in a lake called
sand hammock Lake uh which is in between
esto Florida and Noma Florida no I don't
have any idea where those two places are
probably in the Panhandle I
imagine um now it would kind of like it
still at Liv stock and um people still
tried to kill it like I guess there was
some boys that tried to shoot it with a
rifle and stuff like that but didn't
really uh do anything there was an
article in 1972 about him and there were
some sightings back then um but you know
it it was only been seen like
periodically since then uh they did find
some tracks in 1972 on Bon Island uh in
Florida so that they think belong to
that alligator now starting in
1987 they've actually had a
festival celebrating G uh this isn't
Gustav this is tuto Tom Gustav is the
one we're going to talk about next he's
the grand finale he's the grand fin
finale yeah cuz cuz somebody asked me
about him and I'm like yeah we're going
to talk about him he's the grand finale
yeah cuz he might be still alive he
might be still alive um but yeah so tuto
Tom they have a festival starting in '
87 uh about Tutto Tom in this in esto
Florida um but they don't know if
they're going to keep doing the festival
I guess because interest has waned since
2019 but they have done it every year
since then um another fun fact about
tuto Tom is that he was mentioned in a
novel by Harper Lee goetta Watchmen uh
Harper Lee obviously very famous for
writing toquilla Mockingbird uh and she
wrote about him in another one of her
books so this is a like very well-known
Legend but like I said he does seem to
have been a real alligator that did
actually like kill some people so let's
talk
about the like I said the grand finale
Gustav yeah where where was Gustav from
uh Gustav is uh a Nile crocodile before
we go to to Egypt I want to say
something
about the southern crocodiles I remember
as a
boy the cinjun wing of my family in in
Louisiana Old Friends of the family when
I was like 11 12 I'm talking about old
men that we knew who were in their 70s
or 80s when I was 10 12 years
old they believed the alligator gar to
be more dangerous than the alligator
they said it was bigger faster and more
deadly I don't know if anybody ever
being killed by a gar but they swore by
I never heard that either but maybe they
said that they would swim faster than a
an alligator and you got and it had sh
the teeth were sharper and then it was
more
deadly but that goes against what we
know about the gar although like I said
there are old photographs where they
were trying to exterminate all the gar
out of out of Louisiana out of the out
of the BIOS out in there they would have
electrified paddle boats out there in
the early 1900s shocking them to death
and they would have photographs of some
of them strung up and those things were
[__] 11 feet long according to the
photos and evidently those weren't the
big ones they were just those were just
common ones
they're not that big today there's no
telling how big those things got back in
the day back before people fished them
and killed them all out when there was
you know less humans around and like I
said some of those things could have
been over a 100 years old maybe
150 in my time fishing with my dad in
the 80s 70s and 80s very early
90s I never saw an alligator guardar
bigger than
5et and my dad said no they get lot
bigger than that you
know but just goes along with everything
else I think things used to live long
enough to get a lot bigger than they do
now there's too many people they catch
them and kill them before they get that
big
yeah interesting who knows maybe a
really big alligator gar we're we're
worse than an
alligator but there's no modern
statistics Ben says alligator cars
alligator cars alligator gars alligator
gar g r gar it's a fish yeah it's not
even really a fish they're kind of eels
kind of like an eel yeah but their head
kind of their head kind of looks like an
alligator s f with these sharp teeth
used to catch them but they were never
really big they're ugly ass fish ugly
yeah the fish is half head yeah can't
eat them doesn't matter how big it is
mean you can eat them it's probably
about like eating a eel they don't
really taste Americans don't don't eat
the E nah the Japanese are probably love
it they probably make sushi out of it
yeah gar is it's a gar g yeah there's
other kind of gars but alligator gar is
what we have in the south is what we
have in the South and they call them
that because their head kind of looks
like an alligator yeah when they get
full grown they're the size of an
alligator yeah like I said the biggest
one I've ever seen probably like I said
four or five feet yeah but apparently
they used to get a lot bigger yeah and
apparently there are a lot bigger ones
but I've never seen one
I used to see them in the spring that I
swam in all the time legend legend had
it has it that they used to be 12 to 15
feet that's how big that they got but
they're talking about 1800s in that per
in that period they got that big weird
I'd like to know maybe they are maybe
they do get dangerous when they're that
big I would imagine any fish that was
that size would [__] you up yeah because
you're small enough to eat sure thing is
they tend to skew I they don't they
can't choose they have to swallow things
whole so I don't think they can swallow
a man hole I don't
know depends on how big they actually
get that's what I mean I have seen some
catfish that look like they could
swallow a person that were big enough
but I don't know the guard R today yeah
yeah their mouth is kind of small so I
don't really know cuz you know people
have big heads and big shoulders yeah
that's why snakes have so much trouble
like swallowing us it could have always
been that in the eyes of a Cajun they
were dangerous because they looked more
dangerous didn't necessarily mean that
they I don't know that they I don't know
if I never witnessed any kind of data
that anybody got eaten by one not in the
modern
era they claimed that they used to get
eaten by them though it's just a
mystery Cajun kind of just tells stories
yeah you never know if they're like just
they things were big and they were ugly
so they might oh yeah yeah but you your
your Grandpa Paul got eaten by one of
those you did yeah oh yeah yeah
swallowed him ho [__] we got to kill
them all and they're right there killing
them it's like really pra your grandpa
pa just like died of like Liber fail
your grandpa pa boo he got he he got
eaten by one of them yeah BR gotta eat
one of
those his name is Buro
Tio yeah that was actually your
grandpapa's name wasn't it no my grand
my granddad's name was was bolar that's
right yeah I remember you told me that
bivar Francis
Ross yeah
all right so can we talk about ghab
let's talk about ghab so like I said uh
this
crocodile
um probably this is most of his attacks
took place around um
Bundi and uh probably the largest Nile
crocodile alive yeah uh he's about 20 ft
long weighs about a
ton and he may be the largest individual
predator on the entire African
continent now there's a French
naturalist whose name is Patrice Fay and
he's been studying Gustav for a while he
even did like a documentary on him in
2004 for PBS I believe which is where a
lot of the information about him comes
from they think that this single
crocodile has killed at least 300 people
damn they did talk talk about him on uh
the William Shatner show yeah they
talked about ghostav because he's pretty
famous um and like I said they're not
actually sure if he's still alive or not
he was given the name Gustav by Patrice
Fay how how big was he about 20 feet
that's that's an old alligator yeah he's
a crocodile crocodile he's an crocodile
yeah probably 100 years old at
least yeah that well um as far as I know
the estimate was that he's
about 70 about 70 yeah okay at least
that's what I heard between 65 and 70
they think he might they didn't catch a
beginning of the program they don't know
how long an alligator lives no they
don't they think he might have hatched
in the 50s yeah um because that's I
imagine that's later on when like um you
know reports about him started coming
out so they think that at this stage if
he's still alive which they don't know
if he is um
that he might be between 65 and 70 years
old alligators grow their entire lives
as long as they have enough
food as they grow they need more and
more food per
day and the O and as they age they don't
seem to to be get decrepit at all
they're just as Lively at a 100 as they
are when they're young so they seemingly
could live a long time we know Turtles
can live more than 150
years
so there's a possibility that if an
alligator has enough food regular food
that it may live 150 years growing the
whole time but that's not efficient it's
not efficient in in the natural world in
in in um in nature that means the older
you get the bigger you get the more food
you need to kill each day or on average
each day so your food requirements get
increase as you age that's the limit you
get so big you starve to death
eventually you just can't make your
caloric
intake but millions of years ago when
there were dinosaur everywhere you
probably could because the animals were
bigger so nobody knows the ones in
captivity have lived over a hundred
years I think the oldest one died
because the dude that took care of it
died and it it hadn't eaten a long time
and starve to
death that's that's the story I heard I
don't know if it's true or not sounds
plausible but yeah they made um actually
a movie about this crocodile uh called
Prime Evil which came out in 2007 which
I don't remember if I've seen or not
I've heard it's not very good but it's
uh apparently about him because like I
said he's kind of world famous now
people that live in the area where
Gustav has been
seen um they claim that this C crocodile
just kills people again for shits and
giggles not just not just because he
wants to eat them you know what I mean
um cuz sometimes he'll kill multiple
people in one go and then like not eat
them you know what I mean um and he's
kind of they never know where he's going
to show up next like he's kind of
unpredictable you know what I mean he
kind of has a wide range I
guess uh there's also a story I'm not
sure if this is true or not but that he
actually killed and ate an adult male
hippopotamus which is crazy I would have
love to [__] see that [__] fight
crocodile versus hip I well see somebody
said earlier like what who would win a
fight between well somebody's saying
right here that Gustav won that fight
that he ate a whole hippopotamus I don't
believe it I don't know he I
mean it could
be maybe the hippopotamus was having a
bad day man I don't know you'd have to
drown he'd have to drown the hippo
that's what I mean and and then you'd
have to let the hi hippo
Rock because they can't chew in the way
that normal animal does they just yank
rotten hunks off and swallow them a
whole They Don't Really chew they just
swallow
yeah
so hippo an adult hippo is pretty
[__] massive they are big yeah yeah I
I I doubt that if even a huge Al even a
huge crocodile would attempt it because
you can get
hurt the thing about these [__]
predatory animals they they can't afford
to get hurt because they can't be any
downtime they like to go [__] they like
to go for easy
prey it just sounds like a boast to me
I'd have to see it might be I'm not real
sure yeah I'd have to see that to
believe it apparently though Gustav does
have a bunch of scars on him from where
he's been shot and hit with Spears and
stabbed and [__] because he's a big
[__] and he kills people yeah so
people have been trying to kill him
right but apparently uh no one has
succeeded and he just has all these
scars like all over his head and all
over his body and stuff like that like
from various weapons it sounds a lot
like a modern Dragon doesn't like yeah
that's like a Dragon Story yeah well and
like I said I'm going to
say um I went to when I went to the
alligator farm when I was a kid and they
had the really big crocodile
goac who I saw him alive like he's dead
now and they have him stuffed but I saw
him while he was still alive when I was
younger and that dude
was 18 feet that's huge and he was
terrifying it wasn't so much the length
it was the girth how fat he was huh yeah
he was like super big around the middle
and I was just kind of like holy crap
like if he opened his mouth you could
probably just lay in it right so this
gustab is supposed to be like a couple
feet bigger than that right and I'm not
really sure like how much bigger around
he is I think that's what scared me the
most was how big around that [__]
crocodile was yeah um and this is GOC
I'm talking about who was a little bit
smaller than
gusta I saw a thing about this about
these
guys they can easily starve to death and
they can starve to death while you're
feeding them if they ever get into a
caloric death deficit they can't hardly
ever [__] claw their way back out of
it that's weird when you think about it
you know what I mean
so big alligators like they have to be
fed on
time if they don't if they're not fed on
time yeah they're they start going in a
caloric deficit and then they what they
eat they're kind of making up they're
try to make up for lost time you know
what I mean and they can't eat enough to
make
up that's weird
yeah well caterpillars the same way yeah
just like that once there's a deficit
they can't ever make up the deficit I
think that's how they die when they get
that big I've never heard of One D A
disease you know you could do it by
accident injuries and [__] but yeah yeah
when you're dealing with animals like
that starvation is a different
game I don't know [__] crazy weird
yeah go rest but yeah so this crocodile
like I said because he's so famous and
because he's killed so many people
um the um the naturalist Patrice Fay
he's actually been trying to cap capture
gav he actually doesn't want to kill gav
uh if he finds him he actually wants to
um you know put him in an enclosure so
he can't kill any more people obviously
and maybe use him like in conservation
efforts so there's that in
2004 they did a PBS documentary called
capturing the killer crack and on that
one he was trying
to um basically like build a huge trap
like to capture the crocodile now
apparently um they had spent like a
couple of years like preparing for this
and you know trying to figure out what's
the best way to catch this crocodile and
like you know scoping out the area and
everything like that so they spent two
months building this trap and like
installing it and you know trying to
catch this this uh
crocodile but they couldn't really stay
there for much longer cuz there was like
some kind of uh Uprising in Burundi and
they had to leave because there was you
know kind of war and political unrest
and [__] like that so they couldn't stay
there but they did have a trap cage
installed in um an area where Gustav had
been seen in the past uh they had like a
30 foot
trap now they did find Gustav um and
they tried to like kind of lure him into
the Trap and they like put cameras in
there and [__] like that however it
seems that the crocodile was uh too
smart for
them uh they did put some big snares on
the uh Lake Shore like the shore and
stuff like that they did catch some
smaller crocodiles in those traps but
they did not catch Gustav um now not too
long before they had to leave the
country they had the uh they were kind
of desperate and they're like oh my God
we have to catch this [__] crocodile
for this documentary so they put a live
goat in this 30 foot cage which the goat
was probably like what the [__] did I
ever do to you come on um so the goat's
just standing in there hanging out like
nothing really happened for a couple of
nights but then uh there was a bad storm
the camera got knocked out like the
infrared camera that they have and the
morning after that the cage was found
halfway under water and the Goat was
missing so they don't know if the storm
sort of dislodged the cage to such an
extent that the goat just escaped or if
a crocodile ate the goat or what
happened because the camera got knocked
out so they didn't see you know they had
a camera on it but it wasn't working
obviously so they didn't really know
what was going on so that was kind of
the last time well it was seen after
that but that was kind of you know kind
of the last big effort to like catch
Gustav and they never were able to uh as
I mentioned in 2009 uh he was spotted
near uh Lake tanganika um so he has been
seen then now in 2019 interestingly
there was an article about Burundi in a
travel in travel Africa magazine and in
that article it said that Gustav had
been killed but it didn't give any
specific specifics about it like he
didn't have any photographs or didn't
say who had killed him or what had
happened or anything like that so
nobody's really sure if that was just
like [__] that like somebody was
saying that because they didn't really
have any like evidence that he had but
like I said if he's only if he really
was hatched in the 50s then he'd only be
65 70 years old and that's not old for a
crocodile so he could absolutely still
be out there someplace and like I said a
lot of the people that lived in the area
said yeah he would disappear for like
years at a time time and then he would
pop back up again like he would go
someplace else how old would he be if he
was still alive about 68 yeah is
something like that's what I mean that's
not crazy they live like way longer than
that yeah so he could absolutely still
be alive someplace now he haven't big
early huh he haven't been seen in a few
years but yeah yeah well I'm not really
sure he must have been he must have got
a lot of
food yeah he there weren't really any
reports of him like man eating until
until he was like real big you know what
I mean so it must have been like more
recent that they were those reports were
cuz like I said he ate they think he ate
like 300 people that they know of yeah
that they know of it's weird it kind of
reminds me of uh one in Louisiana where
a guy was flying his little cesna around
and took a
picture of an alligator down down in a
it was in an irrigation
Channel and by looking at the train
features that thing was like close to 30
something feet
long remember that yeah you were seeing
that 30 something foot long that one was
they think that one was an alligator
though yeah but nobody's ever seen it
with their naked eye guy just had a
photograph of
it and it didn't look like it was
hoaxed I mean that's not they over that
thing and they go yeah that's where it
was but and they were looking at the
size of you know this the terrain
features and everything that was in the
photograph that think would have been
about 35 feet long that's [__] huge
man huge for an alligator yeah yeah
huge but no one's seen it I think I
would have a heart attack on the spot if
I saw a [__] out that was 35 ft long
yeah giant oh my God other people call
[__] on it that it was some kind of
cuz like I said photography I saw the
one in St Augustine I saw goch when he
was still alive and he was like 18 19
feet and even that was just kind of like
holy [__] [__] he's like enormous he
was enormous and it's just even that
scared me so it's like if I saw one that
was almost twice that size [__] that oh
my God I remember in that program some
people were saying that that's not
possible there's not enough food out
there for for it to get that big I don't
know I guess it depends on where it I
don't think it's
impossible it would be unusual for sure
but I'll try to look back into it again
yeah try to find that particular one I
mean that's big but it's not he had a
photograph of it crazy oh no wait no he
didn't have a photograph he didn't have
a
photograph
I think he I think he just saw it and
then he knew where it was and then he
drew he was making the estimates at the
time I think he flew over it well that's
a different story yeah I don't think he
had the photograph cuz I'm not good at
estimating like he drew it out I think I
just remember seeing photographs of they
took photographs of the area later they
showed it then they flew over like a
drone and he was saying how big it was
which would have been about 30 something
feet yeah James said 35 ft is
unbelievable there's something wrong or
deceiving you don't hide a 35t alligator
and it was kind of in a drain an
artificial drainage River I mean maybe
if it was in the
Everglades but no it was in Louisiana
yeah where like a lot of people don't go
maybe but in a in a populated area well
on the edge I guess yeah I mean like I
said I don't think it's impossible I've
seen some [__] big ones but even the
big ones are 20t that's crocodiles yeah
and alligators tend to be a little bit
smaller like the biggest alligator I
ever heard of
was 17 feet something like
that I don't know how how was that big
was that one that was walking across the
golf course did they estimate no it was
like 13 feet something like that 12 to
13 it looked a lot bigger than that it
was huge I don't well like I said it's
not so much the length it's like how big
around they are that's kind of what's
yeah his belly was off the ground and it
was walking yeah like I said had a
medieval Knight seen that he'd have said
that that was a dragon and dude I saw a
dragon it was [__] huge you can't
blame him for thinking that either
that's exactly what they look like
gigantic lizard
yikes when we were talking about gar
before Ben said garfish I know they're
in the monster
[Laughter]
manual yeah those are real we call them
alligator go well like I said there are
several different species of
gar they just call that one species
alligator gar because what their head
looks like it looks like an alligator
kind there's other fish that are just
regular gar you know what I
mean all right so I think that's the
last story so are you ready to wrap it
up how long have we been on 3 hours and
35 minutes hey guys got a long show
tonight we did yeah well it was fun
though talking about man eating animals
we always like to talk about that kind
of Stu stuff uh DVD Dragon said Gustav
is on Tren is on a trend dball stack oh
yeah always making gains yeah
anest he's got to have his test base and
then he's just eating people left and
right yeah he's got his test base that's
what happens and he's got his [__]
dball and he's got Tren
running on anavar pills too right along
with it he does
everything yeah he's on to Gustav secret
yeah he's in there just like doing clo
stes in the gym yeah can you like a
little COC Little Crocodile like lifting
weights and stuff well big crocodile
James says side tangent on size guessing
a group of scientists guessed the length
of an anaconda everyone guessed 50 to 70
feet was at was only 35t okay still a 35
foot anaconda um I would not [__] with a
35 foot
anaconda so that's quite big enough for
me yeah they get big thanks like that's
big enough to eat me and I don't really
want to be eating by a snake
particularly either probably not quite
as bad as getting eat by a shark or a
crocodile like I said but still not fun
the guy in question it was like some
kind of artificial River for irrigation
it went something it was around uh if I
remember correctly it was around some
kind of a chemical
plant or or fertilizer plant something
like
that he was flying over
it and he was trying to estimate it its
length and it was like 30 something feet
but a lot of people call [__] on it
he was drawing it and he he tried to
take people down there they tried to
they tried to find
it they never did he saw something but I
don't think it was that
big like I said it's kind of hard to
estimate size probably a 17 foot
alligator which is still horrifying big
that's still big yeah but not 35t yeah
like I said I would ship my pants by
remember correctly like 30 something Fe
ft yeah yeah
giant he was saying where his nose was
and where the tail was on you know what
it looked like from one side of the bank
and the other you know I mean because it
was in a channel
basically sad says Jen do you know the
YouTube channel the Y files yeah I've
heard of it I've only seen like a couple
of their videos but that's probably I
think I'm subscribed to them actually
but I don't watch that much of their
stuff but yeah I have heard of it yeah
James said he could have seen 17 ft and
just overestimated yeah if I remember
correctly he circled circled over it and
then it submerged he couldn't see it and
he lost sight of it yeah it was up on
the surface when he saw it and I mean
that's not always crazy because there
was kind of wasn't one of those big
giant anacondas like they saw it from
the air and he's just like oh my God it
was like however long and they were like
yeah you're full of [__] but then they
found it later and they're like oh yeah
you're right it was [__] gigantic and
it had like eaten a person or something
but yeah there there is like some big
[__] out there um yeah James says
have a good night you guys yeah we're
going to wrap it up it's
1103 here in nice cold Florida
403 degrees 45 degrees I can't it's 45
degrees 45 degrees Fahrenheit in
Florida I love it I love it it's cold I
know I like it I finally get to wear
like long sleeves and stuff yay I'll
probably be hot again tomorrow but you
know I'll I'll take it when I can get it
but yeah thanks everybody for dropping
by this evening thank you for your super
chats remember to click on the link in
the description box uh for a 30-day free
trial of audible uh they're are sponsor
and affiliate so you know we get a
little bit little bit of a commission
every time somebody clicks on that and
gets a membership so you can support the
show that way if you would like to so
remember to come back on Friday night
for our Sidetrack show we're just going
to drink and talk about [__] more
than we did on this show you know uh so
yeah so that should be fun thanks
everybody for dropping by and hanging
out with us this evening we will see you
again on Friday night good m